anding by.
>> Ladies and gentlemen,dan
Kaufman
, director of Google ATAP.
>> Hey.ou. Good morning, e
verybody.  I am, I'mdan Kaufman.
One year ago, almost to this d
ay, Google asked me to come and
help lead ATAP.  I remember s
itting in my hotel rope watching
the ATAP I/O presentation, and
I was just fascinated with this
idea we could bridge the gap
between our physical world and
our digital lives.  I was moved
by this insistence that we
remember our humanity, take our
human nature and embed it in
technology and I could not wait
to come here.
And now it's one year later, and
I'm the head of ATAP.  I get to
share with all of you some of
the stuff we've been working on
over the last year., and I could
not be more excite ed.
We have a completely packed show
.  I'm going to give you a very
brief overview and we're just
going to get to it.
One thing I get asked a lot when
I go out around and I talk
about ATAP is what does success
mean?  How do you measure it,
how do you know you're
successful, what becomes success
?  We'll talk a little bit about
that.
Then we're going to get you
caught up and give you an update
on projects Jakard and solely,
two projects we showed you.  We
showed you some really early
prototypes of that and we're
going to show you how it's made
its journey as we've worked with
some you have as developers and
some commercial partners on its
way to become ing a product.
And then of course we've got to
talk about ARA.  Who does not
want to talk about it?
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Yes.
So we've got an update for you.
Finally as has been our
tradition over the last two
years, we're going to end with a
new spotlight story.  This year
we've got a really special
twist and I hope you like it.
Let's first talk about success
and what it means to us.
In order for me to tell you what
success means for a project at
ATAP, I have to take you back to
the beginning.
Everything at.  ATAP starts with
a person and a passion and an
idea.  And that idea is often a
little bit crazy.  It's sort of
borders right on that line
between what's possible and
what's impossible.  So the first
thing we do is we do a deep
scientific dive to try to find o
ut and make sure that still it
really lives within the realm of
what's possible.
And if we conclude that it does,
then we dig in and we work on
it, usually for a year,
sometimes more, and it's hard.
It's really hard.  It's hard
because there's no precedence
for what we do.
There's just nothing out there
like that before, and so we have
to invent things.  We have to
invent new materials.  We have
to invent new testing rigs, new
software concepts.  And we
often hit roadblocks.  And we
stumble and we fall, and we get
back up again and we fight and
we persist, .  And we do it
because it's important
important and because we
believe in this idea.
And then something magical
happens.  We see this little
glimmer of light at the end of
the tunnel and we think, holy
cow, this thing that was just an
idea may be real, and we go to
the lab and it's there and it
exists.  And at that moment we
turn to developers, such as y
ourselves, and commercial
partners, and we ask one simple
question:  If we can make this
thing exist not just in a lab
but in the real world, what
would you do with it?  What
could you build?  What products
could it be?  How could we
impact people's lives?  How do
we get things into the hands of
people?  But most importantly,
we ask them a simple question:
Do you want to come on this
journey with us?  And when they
say yes, things begin to change.
They inject all sorts of new
energy, they have all sorts of
ideas, they want 20 take
technology places we never
imagined.  We encounter all
sorts of problems we never
thought of before, and more i
mportantly they come up with s
olutions to these problems that
below       blow our minds.  All
of a sudden these fledge
fledgling ideas start to become
prototypes and prototypes
become products.  So success for
us is when our projects make
this transition.  Because after
all, for things to matter,
people have to be able to use
them.  These transitions happen
many different ways.  I'm going
to give you three brief examples
.  Three may give you a feel but
we've had a whole bunch.
About two years on the IO stage,
Johnny ily wondered
wonder           ny Lee wondered
if we could map the same we
way we map the outside world.
He showed prototypes.  With
claiive vor and the team, they
took tank      Tango from these
early protein types to a product
you'll be able to buy later
this year from Lenovo.
>> Whewed hoo.
>>
>> Whoo-hoo.
>> Yeah, go buy one. talked
about Avicus, this wase pack
chop pray's vision to get rid of
the things -- we have these
phones and have all these sense
ors, why couldn't they diswrus
just      they just
know so I can just work.
They've taken these ideas and
turned it into a trust API.
What we're going to do with this
is be able to get rid of the a
wkwardness of second factor
authentication.  This June we're
going out to several large
financial institutions for
initial testing.  Assume ing it
goes well, this should become
available to every Android
developer around the world by
the end of the year.  I cannot
wait to see what you guys build
with it.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>
Now, sometimes -- transitions
don't happen on a schedule.
Sometimes they just pop up and
surprise you.  And so I kind of
wanted to share this one with
you because nobody's ever seen
it outside of our shop.  A while
ago we were looking at this
slide, and this is a very
complex slide      slide.  So d
on't worry about it.  Here's the
bottom line.  There's an
epidemic in congestive heart
failure and costs us millions of
lives and dollars.  What we do
today to help people with that
is we do surge and we use what w
e call an invase ive sensor.
You put a sensor in the chest
and it helps monitor people's
health.  We saw this as a be p
ro.  We wondered if I could
replace these invase ive sensors
with non    noninvase ive
sensors, wouldn't that be
amazing?  All of a sudden the
cost of healthcare could drop,
we could give this to everybody,
you wouldn't need surgery which
is risk      risky       risky
and we shared that vision with
jestsa megga and an do Conrad,
feet part of life sciences.
Would he have transitioned our
people and our technology and IP
because we want to get this
developed as fast as possible
and we could not think of
anybody better off to do that.
Hopefully you will get that in
everybody's hands as soon as
possible.
So for us that's what success
looks like.  After all, ideas
are most meaningful when put
into practice.  So today that's
what I want to focus on.  I want
to focus on this journey that
we take you on from an early
idea to to a prototype to just
the beginning glimmers of a
commercial application.  So
let's get started.
Last year Dr. Yvonne Pufra i
ntroduced to two projects, p
roject Sol  oly and Jacgar  aurd
.
To give you an idea for that
journey and update, Dr. Ivan Puf
rev.
>> Thank you.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Good morning. So let's talk
about project Soly and Jacqaur
urd.
We did new technology to create
connected close.  We also
announce ed partnership with
Levis.  And there was a lot of s
peculation --
There was a lot of speculation
what are they going to make at
them.  Let's look at one of them
.
>> Apparently Google's
developing a new digital type of
fabric that you can touch and
can feel it and it also blue
Bluetooths to your phone.
Now you can swipe the side of
your jeans to mute your phone,
even tap the fabric for playing
any song, which means pretty
soon all your calls can be
Bullet        butt dials.
>> Butt dials, seriously?
That's a million dollar idea for
you.
We're not make ing
make ing smart pants
, almost accurate.  Instead, the
very first Jacqaurd garment is
going to be Levi     Levi's
commuter truck jacket, fashion
able and functional.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> To wear on and off the bike.
And to tell you why, the jacket
is a perfect feature for
Jacqaurd, I would like to invite
on stage Paul from Levi's.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Thank you. Thanks very much
for that destruction but we
actual
introduction.  It's hard to
believe it was a year ago at
Google I/O 15 we were introduced
.  145 years since Levi's i
nvented the blue jean.  Today is
the actual official birthday of
the blue jean.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> For 143 years at Levi's we've
been make ing clothing with
purpose.  It started in the 18
hundreds make ing durable cloth
ing for the mine rs for the gold
crush.  Purposeful design years
later to meet the urban cyclist
.  Make quality clothes that p
erform as great as they look.
It's in that context I'm excited
to talk to you about today's n
ewest edition to the commute er
family, which is the trucker
jacket powered by Google's
Jacqaurd technology.
Anyone who rides a bike knows
that tension.  How do you go on
a ride without going off grid?
Anyone who rides a bike knows
it's a terrible idea to try to n
avigate the screen of your phone
while you're navigating busy
city streets.  This technology
gives us a first-time real world
solution to that real world
problem.
Now, if you imagine the
opportunity for woven tactile
interface in the context of the
most explicit and urgent needs
of an urban cyclist, that's
safety and awareness, the
opportunity becomes really real,
valuable.  This becomes a
copilot for your ride and your
life, both on and off the bike.
This is a good friend helping
you out.  So now to access the
most necessary pieces of your
digital life, you simply touch
the sleeve of your jacket.
This is a customize ed connect
ivity.  This is maximize ed
awareness and minimize ed
distraction.  All of this
without sacrificing the style of
a great looking Levi's trucker
jacket.  So now if you want to
answer a phone call or block a
phone call, if you want to wroal
your music
control your music, drop a pin t
o make a personal map of the
city, access navigation so you
can get lost and get found, all
of that can be done with a
gesture, a tap, a swipe.
Now, you might think this kind
of technology would be precious,
but we're not make ing
make ing Levi's trucker gadgets;
we're make ing trucker jackets.
Jean jackets.  This is a tough
technology.  At the end of the
day you can throw in your
backpack.  Just drop it on the
floor.  If you get this thing
dirt ty, you put it in the wash
ing machine.  This is friendly,
easy-going technology.  This is
technology you can wash.
[LAUGHTER]
>> But enough out of me, we
should take a look at it in
action.  I'm going to go throw o
ne on while we watch a video
video.
[
APPLAUSE ]
ÔÖź
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> So Paul is going to come back
in show the jacket in a
secretary, and before
second, before t
hat let's take a look at Google
Jacqaurd.  It's a platform, not
just another warble.  A platform
to create smart connected
clothes.  Consists of a garm
garment with some wear in
the cuff.  A piece of
electronic, Jacqaurd tag, which
connects your jacket to the LED
optics, and also a battery to
spar      power the jacket.
Uses custom connecting in the
cuff to do that.
The Jacqaurd jacket can be
charge ed from any USB computer.
We also have a Jacqaurd app on
the phone which connects your
jacket to services in the cloud.
There is a unique challenges
in create ing smart clothes in
platform.  Fashionable clothes
has to work as one, but between
the two, floarks, when we design
or jacket for the first time,
we were compromise ing garment a
esthetics.  The first design was
like this, straight line.
Engineers like everything simple
.  Everything's visible,
everything easy to understand.
However, this is not denim.  It
was not authentic and it didn't
look good.  So there we went the
other way around is and made it
completely invisible, but now
.  So we were working w
ith our customers in Japan and
in Levi's and design a new look,
weask techniques which blended
into fabric, made it both v
isible and invisible while p
reserving an authentic den
minimum look.
In fashion fit matters.  You
have any size from extra small
to extra large.  Don't have that
in technology world.  That's
why our Jacqaurd tag is still
flexible so it can bend around t
he cuff of any size and fit a ja
cket of any size.  The design
was inspired by the design of
classic trench colt     colt.
Though it looks simple, it was a
long road to make it just right
.
It has to be row     robust.
Technology is fragile.  Garments
Garment is, very
diewrnl         durable.  These
days you don't have to pull with
two horses to prove it really
works.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Those days are behind us. at
least you have to be able to
wash it at the very least.
In our first test, our yarns
would brei after one or two
washes.  So we went on and
worked hard to understand the
reason of failure, analyze our
yarn with a microscope and put
them to the point where we
exceed Levi's durability.  We
don't have to treat Jacqaurd j
acket any differently from
regular jacket.
ly, clothes are made by make ers
not by consumer electronic
maker.  It is our vision that
any apparel         apparel
apparel make er should
not only be
manufacture their own supply
chain because we want to empower
the power industry to create
this new product platform. wo
rking with Levi's, we set up
production in the same facility
ies and same location as the
regular Levi's production.
Same        Use the exactly same
processes to wave our
would he have been our den
processes to we've our
denim.  You burn with open f
lames.  Our technology went
through the same thing.
The final denim was shipped to
the aim is I seembly
assembly technique, same t
echniques as a regular denim
jacket.  Industrial washing.
Every gar meant goes
garment goes through
that.  We added some testing
facilities to understand how it
works at the exit, but at the
end it's a regular jacket.  It
was good and makes you look
great.
SE ]
>> I guess what I want to say
that Jacqaurd jackets is
foremost a jacket, it protects
you from wind and rain, keeps
you warm, and makes you look g
reat.  But much more than a
jacket.  As the user of this
jacket, you will be able to
configure it to connect your
favorite services, such as c
ontrol calls and messages from
the phone or use your favorite
Google services, Google maps,
Play, or others.  You can use
third-party services such as
Spotify, and already working
with third parties to include
their support to the jacket.
And finally, it can be custom
services developed by you by
developers, and we will be
releasing APIs to allow you to d
o that.
Furthermore, we try to expand to
go beyond bike ing and going to
work with athletics, business
wear, and enterprise.
But first things first.  Our
jacket is going to be released
on the market in spring 2017.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> But you don't have to wait
that long.  And you can help us
to improve the product by
-- now let's take a
look at the jacket.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> I'll set this right here.
There we go.  So it's a jean j
acket, right
?  It's got some great formal
modifications.  The forms have
been adapt      adapted to be
most useful for the cyclist.
Little things like the back's a
little longer than the front so
you don't have that unfortunate
gap when you're in your bike st
ands.  Also got a full flex
extension in the back.  You've
got maximum range of motion and
localize ed venting to keep you
cool and comfortable on your
ride.
It's got a knit storm cuff right
here so it holds close against
your wrist and doesn't let wind
come up when you're on your bike
.  The real magic happens over
here on this sleeve.
>> As you can see --
>> You can see fully response
ive to the wear against the fab
ric.  So there's a bunch of
different things it can do.
Ivan, let's pick a few --
>> This is application installed
in the jacket right now.
Forty-five --
>> No, thank you, I don't need
the bird counter today.
>> So we have music -- we
installed music in Compass for
you so it can control you.
>> I love to listen to music on
my bike.  I don't listen to this
song.  There we go.  That's my
bike jam.
Okay.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Now, my next meeting after
this is going to be over at Levi
's stadium.  I know how to get
there but I just like to know
how long it's going to take me.
>> Yeah, good idea.
>> Your ATA is 41 minutes. You
should arrive by 11:01 a.m.
>> All right. I got to go. If
I'm going to make that ride I
got to get out of there.
>> Thank you much.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>
new materials that allow us to
use embedded interactions in
every day objects such as cloth
ing.  In our next project, pro
ject Soly, we explore how we can
use small set of finger
gestures to control everything
around us.  In technical turns,
Soly can be described as a small
, tiny
radar for sense ing.  We c
reated new radar senses running
at six gigahertz that can track
hand gesture using normal
algorithms we developed.
The algorithm are really fine g
estures such as rubbing your
fingers together which allows us
to get completely new
newjest     gesture languages
and gesture to the phases faces.
face             faces.
One move     movement is a s
lide er or a button.  And using
this control should be able to
control any device around you
with this same set of gestures,
wearables, speakers or any other
objects.
We show this vision last year at
Google I/O and showed the proof
of concept and the potential of
Soly captured people's
imagination.  It felt very
future risk, almost science
We focused on bringing the
science fiction into reality to
developers and products.  That
was our goal.r first step was
release a Soly develop kit,
which we did in October last
year.  The key to everything you
need to develop your projects.
Hardware, software, libraries,
documentations, everything you
need.  It was early work.  We
sent it to about 60 developers,
from 180 applications coming
from 14 countries.  We were
quite encourage ed by diversity
of the projects people built
using our sensor.  In this e
xample people are using Soly to
recognize materials, such as
copper or milk or water copper.
People use it for image ing.
Touch interaction.  In-car r
emote control.  To unlock your
things, security and password
with gestures.  And compose and
play music.
[ APPLAUSE ]
So this is selection, very first
selection, very first few
projects developed by developers
using our Soly sensor.
Developing and launching for
deaf kid was important milestone
, first of its kind, first radar
you can play in your own
workshop or research lab.
we showed last year was design
ed to run in control
controlled environment and
social lab and can allow it to
relate possibility ies over the
radar for interaction but cannot
be really build product with
it.  For example, it was using
so much power that our legal
department asked me to put this
label on the back of the
development kit.
[LAUGHTER]
>>
Although solar chip was very
small, still required a large
computer to run it.  Defeated
the purpose.  So to prove that
Soly is not just a future risk
concept, it can work inside of
the lab, we decide ed by yiewfg
Google I/O, not only we going to
improve it but make it run on a
smart watch      watch.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> So the way I think about
it, you can make it run
anywhere you want.  So setting
this kind of goal, it creates to
the team that the product is
exponential, not incremental
incremental.  For
example, we had to drastically
decrease size and power of the
entire system.
By working with our partners,
we completely designed a solar
chip.  We optimize ed
agriculture
algorithms of the system
architecture and reduce ed power
consumption 22 times, from 1.2
wait to 54 mill wait.
54 medical            54
mill link rel=stylesheet WAT
WATT.
>
> As I mentioned there's a
computer around Soly.  Now,
requires super computer for the
image ing tracking, satellite
playing or something like that.
Now we don't have super
computer.  This is our embedded
platform.  Uses the same process
ers as a watch.  By optimizing
our pipeline and algorithms, we
were able to achieve 256
reduction in code performance
while maintaining 80,000 per
second through the radar.
So you don't have to compromise
your performance for small phone
factor.  And by the way, it's
already on Android
Android.
[
APPLAUSE ]
>> Nothing's free in this world,
and there are trade-offs.  I
want to talk about one of them.
With every hardware reduction,
with every improvement of our
algorithms           algorithms,
we change the radar signal.
This is something we called a
collection of single artifacts
that have to discover and find a
work Arnold             \work
around\workaround.  Some
work
work around.  Images, ghost
targets        targets.  A lot
of these glitches are new and
the result of our aggressive
reduction in hardware and
software.  So this is on-going
research and development work.
Now, I can talk more about the
challenges and problems, but l
et's get to the watch.  Let's
show the watch.  This is the
first watch we developed.  Does
look like a watch.  Working with
our partners electronics
company, research team     team,
we actually build the first
watch.  It looked like that.
But this time radar was embedded
into the belt of the watch.  We
see in the field it looks like
a watch.
So we went on a shrink
hardware further.  This is very
tiny chip on the left.  Here it
is, a watch with Soly already
neds      inside.
I have
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> I have it on my wrist too.
It can even show time.
[LAUGHTER]
>> That's how awesome technology
is.
>> Now our goal is not to create
just a smart
watch but new intersections.
Nick Gillan or machine engineer
to show how it works.  Before
let's give you a preview of what
you're going to be seeing on
the screen.
What Soly allows to do is expand
interaction.  All of the touch
screen into the 3D space around
it.  We don't have to use a tiny
screen.  Don't have to try to
hit small targets.  Use the
whole space around the watch.
So we split the space in two big
parts to interact with i
nformation on the watch, we did
largeststures around the watch.
Can move your hand like this
and scroll through messages or
see interface for information.
If you want to navigate the
interface of the watch, you can
use virtual tools as I talked a
bout, virtual dials and buttons,
so you can put your hand next
to the watch and use them to nav
igate interaction and interface
elements.
Let's take a look how it works
and I'll get nick to
Nick to show it.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Thank you.
Let's take a look at the watch.
You can see as my hand
approaches, it starts to react.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> The response iveness and
precision of radar enables us to
create these continuous fluid i
nteractions.  The blue bar here
you can see corresponds to my
proximity to the device.  This
enables me to glance at
information at a distance.  So
here, for example, I can see
I've got four unread messages.
If I come a little closer I can
see the names of the users who
sent them.  The precision of
Soly enables me to interact with
my new detail, such as this
scrolling type ography.  If I
move a little closer, I can now
preview the contents of
the first message.
>> You can see how Soly allows
us to take the contents on the
display and actually move them
to this      the space around
the watch.  If I move my hand,
it resets.  Okay, but what if I
want to interact with more
detail?  That's easy.  I just
move my hand closer to the watch
and now I can use a virtual
dial gesture to interact with
the complications.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> So here you can see I'm using
a virtual dial g
esture to rotate through these
various complications.  We've g
ot the messages, the weather,
and the calendar.  These g
estures represent interactions
with physical controls, such as
using an  anlog dial.
Because I don't have to touch
the screen, we can get a lot
more information on the display
and of course just because
they're micro gestures, doesn't
mean I have them right next to
the device.  They also work at a
distance.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> So let's select one of the o
ther applications, the weather,
for example.  I'll remove my ha
nd and now I want to come back
in.  I can instantly look at
what the next weather
information is.
So you can see with just a few
silly gestures, we can already
start to build these rich
intersections               \i
nteraction\intersections
Soly embedded
\interaction\intersection
interaction
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> We have another demo. You're
going to show it.  You're very
good at that.
So we figured it as a generic to
control all sort of devices
with a very simple set of g
estures.  To explore Soly beyond
wearables, we decide ed to take
it in collaboration with Harmon
and their JBL brand.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> So here Soly allows you to
control devices from a distance
without touching
touching them.  This is a very
first prototype, very early work
, but the idea here is exactly
the same interaction principles
and same gestures we design for
watch also allow
us to control the speaker, you
can see.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> It's a different embody iment
but principles are the same.
As approaching his hand, you can
see the speaker recognize and r
eacts to it.
>> So note that the interactions
here are much large er than the
watch, they're several feet.
The sensor can
sense up to around 15 meters.
We can do some pretty amazing
stuff with this.  This is the
same thing that's in the watch.
>> Same algorithms.
>> As I approach, I can now use
the virtual tool to turn on it.
ÔÖźÔÖź
>> Let's try another track.
>> What do you think? Next one?
ÔÖźÔÖź
>> Yeah, that's pretty cool.
Okay, but I can also do other
gestures, more immediate ones,
like shut up.
[
APPLAUSE ]
>> Thank you to Nick. to con c
onclude, Soly's destruction for
connected world, it proposes new
universal experience across
multiple products.  It can be
wearable, mobile, automatickive
automotive, it's
all up to your imagination.  It
offers a third dimension of
interaction which compliments
and enhances other modality ies
such as touch screen and voice
input.  We don't fight with them
; we work together.
In working with our partners
such as Harmon, LG, and others,
we want to bring this new
experience to products.  But you
don't have to wait until it
becomes a product.
Next year we're launching next
version of a Soly development k
it.  This        The Soly by
theta kit.  This will be
embedded low power and based on
module design.  What you have is
Soly going to be this size and
can put in your products or
projects and explore the use of
Soly and ideas in our designs.
We're looking forward to
exploring Soly with you..
[
APPLAUSE ]
>> Pretty cool, yeah? So thanks
to Nick and Ivan and Paul.  Do
I have the coolest job in the
world or what?
[ APPLAUSE ]All right.  So I
promise you we would talk about
ARA A    ARA.  For those of you
who may be new, it's our vision
for the future of phones, and e
ven more so our vision for an
entirely new hardware ecosystem.
For those of you following ARA
for a while, you may be wonder
ing what's going on with A  ARA,
where is it?  And most
importantly when do I get one?
>> Would Whoo! Gley
>> Yeah. We've talked about
this journey from concept to
prototype.  It's made so much
progress it's actually spun out
into its own business unit.
With our asbestos Rick who's
here.  It's going by Richard
wool rich.  The process we made,
Rafa Kamargo.
[ APPLAUSE ]> Thank you, Dan.
For the last year we've been w
orking with users, developers,
and partners.  We've implemented
a new set of technology ies to
create a seamless experience.
Most importantly we put
it where it counts.
Let's take a look.
This is the developer's e
dition.
[
APPLAUSE ]
>> We've integrated the phone
technology in the frame that
frees up space for modules that
we'll create and integrate new
functionality that you can not
get on your smartphone today
.
Has
sick slots.  They're built for
flexibility.  You can put any
module anywhere.  All slots are
generic and support any
functionality.  Each slot
supports up to 11.6 gigabytes
per second while consume ing
consume ing 1/3 of the
USB3 power.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> They are interconnected via
union       Uni pro network.
That allows you to draw video to
a coprocessor for realtime
processing.  It's ready for the
most advance ed high performance
applications.
Modules are assigned to work
with a variety of form factors.
Future frames can be large er,
they can be smaller or something
completely different than a
smartphone.  Car modules will
work with feature frames.
Future modules, we work with
current frames.  Protecting the
investment of both users and
developers in modules.
So how do you add functionality
to your ARA?  Step one, plug in
a module.  Step two, use it.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> all right, guys. Smile.
There you go.
It's
that simple, that easy.  No
hunting four drivers
for drivers
.
You select the module you want
to release from the set
settings app.  Tap it.  Then
when I turn it, so it doesn't
fall
-- I may have gone too far on
that.  Let me try that again.
Let's try it a different way.
Okay, Google, eject the camera.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> There you go.
Over this last year --
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Over this last year we build
a tag not just for a smartphone
but for a truly modular compute
ing platform.  Our silicon has
implemented the world's first Un
i pro network.  High speed, low
power, and application
independent.  Future proof and
this time from the ground up for
mobile.  The module connector
is built for the speed of Uni
pro and robust.  After
10,000 connect cycles.  And
electro mechanical latch built
with memory alloy and controlled
from software, as you saw, c
reate ing an intuitive module
release experience.  Gray bus,
the ARA software stack, enables
runtime detection and use of mod
ules.  You just plug it and it
works.
And we have abstracted all these
this technology in a
baseplate.  So developers can
focus on their technology while
users will be guaranteed a
consistent user experience when
using ARA modules.  The
baseplate is the equivalent of a
software          software API.
ARA is an open platform.  We
want to create a highway ec
osystem on the
scale of the software app
ecosystem.  And to talk about w
hat we're doing with modules and
with next with ARA is our head
of create ive.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Thank you, Rafa.
Good morning.
So as we've been developing the
phone, we've also been create
ing modules, and we started with
modules that improve current
phone functionality ies.  Better
speakers, high resolution
camera
, and expandable storage.
But we also wanted to make ARA
personal.  We've developed
modules with words, with
concrete, and modules we added
color to it.
We've also been exploring s
econdary displays, various steps
of sensors and new technology
ies that you can't find on phone
s today.
ARA is the combination much
would you tell
beauty and function, but also
about solve ing user needs, .
Diabetes, over 6 million adult
Americans who have diabetes
check their glucose level
several times a day.  For that
they have to carry many devices,
a phone and a
glucometer.  We thought, hey,
what if we could put all this
into a module to create a better
glucometer?  Well, it would be
in your phone so it would be a
lot more compact, right?  You
could also add context to the
measurement.  If if it was
really done after sitting or
after exercise ing.
Now, the great news with ARA is
we don't have to get -- we've
been partnering with best in
class companies to develop
modules with us.  Companies that
are already familiar with a
module space.  Some electro
mechanics, home entertainment,
pen sonic           Panasonic,
tow sheeshbia and Harmon.  Other
great products have built great
products and never had the
chance it and opportunity to
have their technology on phones
phones.  Companies like K
ohero, I health, backtrack, and
Got    Gotana.  Now we have a
phone.  We have a set of modules
.  Well, now we need your help.
So later this year we'll be
launching the developer edition
of ARA.  It would contain a
phone, a few modules or
essentially anything you need to
start building.  We'd like to
ask you to think about what are
the modules that you want to
create.  There's more to come.
We've been working on the
consumer version of ARA.
[ APPLAUSE ] be     Will be li
ght, and beautiful and we'll
launch it next year.
Mean while, I'd like to give you
a glimps of           glimpse
of what life with ARA could be l
ike.  Thank you.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>
ÔÖźÔÖź
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> So thanks to Rafa and blaze.
Rafa and I hydrocodone and I
have worked together for a
while.  You would think he would
know better, the key is make
ing ARA yours and he left it up
here, and now ARA is mine.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Thank you.
So as we said, we wanted to end
the show with talking a little
bit about spotlight stories, and
one of the reasons we wanted to
do that is a core ten nent of A
TAP is to remember not to lose
the human inside all this t
echnological wonder.  At AI
Disneyland            Disney
legend Glen King drew to life d
ew wet before our very eyes.  We
had Justin Lynn's live action
take over L.A. in 360.  That
shook our I/O session.  Well,
this year we have a really
special treat for you, but I can
think of no better way to talk
about our latest spotlight story
than just introducing Rashi Alg
arab.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Thank you.
So 2016 has been a big year for
360 and VR.  Enthuses have their
early iest headsets and 360
video and cameras are now become
ing main stream.  The one
question that keeps coming up
over and over is can we tell
stories in this new medium.  Can
we make films like the ones we
love and ones that move us.
We've been working on this for a
while before 360 cameras and b
efore the new VR.
Besides all the efforts for
capturing or create ing immerse
ive worlds around you, we cannot
forget one important essential
factor in storytelling
.
The stories have setups, c
omplications resolutions, they
have beginnings, middles and
ends that need to make sense.  A
structure without which we're e
asily confused or maybe not
interested.
What's most important for being
able to tell a story to an
audience is manage ing their
attention.  It
easy for me to get your
attention right now.  I'm here
on the the stage and you're
seeing your chair is facing the
right way and you know the next
thing is going to happen here.
But when you're immerse ed in a
story, it's all around you.  But
how do we tell you where should
you look?  How do we tell you
where the next thing's going to
happen?  How do we keep you from
getting lost or just missing an
important moment in the story?
Google spotlight stories came
out of this challenge by being
able to create immerse ive s
tories with a structured editor,
giving film makers the tool so
they can get the right impact
from their story even when you t
he viewer are in control of the
camera.  And we do that through
interactive techniques that are
tune ed to manage and respond to
your attention as you're
watching without you notice ing.
Attentionneering.
stories will wait for you to
look the right way.  And where
it's easy to get lost in a big
360 video, our camera will
dynamically guide you without
take ing control to get the best
framing for the action, like
here we see you're interested in
this monster.  So we'll keep
you on it.
And if you get lost in the cloud
s, we will not only reward you
with a change of music, but a
helpful actor will come over and
help you and guide you back to
the main story.
And if you're just still curious
and want to look around, well,
you might discover sub plots.
Gaps in other scenes, because
this world is alive around you.
Sometimes you have to watch
over and over before you get all
of them.  And we know these
techniques work because we p
artnered with award winning film
makers, master's of their craft
s, and we created actual films.
In CG animation, in classic
hand drawn animation, and even
holly wood scale live action.
And with our story development
kit, award winning studios used
these and other techniques to
create their own films
films and push immerse ive
storytelling even further,
without one line of code.
In three years eight immerse ive
interactive films with d
ifferent styles and different
voices.  It's a VR film festival
.
Now, with enthusiastic reception
from the animation and film
communities but more importantly
millions of people have already
experience ed these stories
through the window of phone
screen, with VR viewers like
cardboard, and now with big VR
headsets.
All these different films run on
a tiny but powerful game engine
, doing realtime graphics and an
imation 360 video and audio and
enable ing film-like content in
realtime on mobile hardware.
This engine was squeeze ed to
less than 1 megabyte of code.
Smaller than a codec.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> And was delivered to billions
of devices on one of the
largest online video platforms,
YouTube.  Where these
interactive nonlinear films are
accessible as a regular video.
Are
Now, last Christmas we launched
our short called special deliver
y from arrested          a
nimations.  The full environment
of the show had to be streamed
and reconstructed on your device
in less than one second, b
ecause it's 3D and realtime and
you can look anywhere from the
first moment you see it.
With our latest story, we pushed
our compression in nonlinear s
treaming techniques way further.
Twenty-six different
environments, each one bigger
than the whole of the other
story.  Each one lasting only
for a few seconds, and this is
the first show where we
continuously cut from one shot
to the next, 38 shots in less
than six minutes.  And the
engine has to throw away a full
environment every time and bring
in a new one each time seamless
ly, perfect sync, without a
hitch.  And more so with four
four emby sonnic tracks, 3D
position of audio, this was the
most complex and rewarding
sound experience we've ever
created.
The story's called Pearl and is
presently merge today on YouTube
premiering today on
YouTube.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Now, before you go check it
out, I would like you to hear
from the director himself.  He's
known for animation on big
Tennessee           Disney films
like where he can it Ralph and
award win    winning shorts
called paper man.  Last year he
picked up his own academy award
for a beautiful short called
feast.  What do you do after you
win an Academy Award?  You make
a spotlight story.
So, ladies and gentlemen, the
creator of Pearl, Patrick
Osborne.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Thanks, Rashid?
A little over a year ago I
showed up Google right down the
street here and met the amazing
minds at ATAP and I took over
one of their fame ed whiteboard
covered conference rooms and
began to draw up an idea, and I
wanted to make something
memorable, beautiful, and maybe
meaningful.  And I didn't know
it then but I was very lucky to
have met this particular group,
these geniuses at ATAP, because
I didn't know it yet but I was
asking for something that was
really hard, maybe impossible to
do.  I wanted to make this
short,
Pearl, a six-minute fully
animated 360-degree short road
trip musical that takes place
entirely in a beet        a
beat-up 1980 sedan with 15
characters, more environments
that many feature films, and
just create ing, designing and
create ing that many sets is a
lot to handle, but on top of
that they need to be rendered in
realtime on a phone.  And
apparently that's hard.
[LAUGHTER]
>> So my background is in
animation.  I've been working in
feature films for the last 13
years, and animaters are control
freaks.  We make everything
from scratch in every scene, but
this mobile platform was
different.  It was going to be a
film without a frame.  The
audience, not me, the director,
gets to decide where the camera
goes and that feels like a lot
of control to give up at first.
But I thought about maybe
turning those limitations into
something that would inspire the
story.  So film makers have
been using artificial frames
within frames for -- since the
beginning of time, or beginning
of film.  If we set this film
entirely in a car, I could get
my fill of these pretty
compositions by make ing frames
with the car windows themselves.
So what kind of story takes
place in a car?  I love road
trip movies, so I thought maybe
we'd make one of those, and we
let the audience sit in the
passenger's Saturday
seat and treat it more like
theater than film, where I try
to spotlight the action and
direct the attention of the
audience, but it's completely
okay if they wander, and I made
sure the story would read no
matter what direction they were
looking, even if you're not
looking the right way. it would
be some sort of road trip giving
tree kind of story, maybe a
story about passing down your
car, and I thought what else do
we pass on?  Personality ies,
tastes and talent maybe?  I used
to draw with my dad as a kid.
He's a toy designer.  And I
think more than any of the
physical things he gave me, in
cluding my high school '89 civic
hatchback, the thing I value
most is the time we spent
together drawing when I was a
kid.  He passed on a sense of
visual taste and the love of
putting pen to paper, and I
think considering what I do now,
it's probably the most valuable
thing he ever gave me.
So I decide ed to make Pearl
that, the story about passing on
an object, your car, but also
handing down a passion or a t
alent.  In this case, not
drawing.  It was going to be
music.  It was going to be a
musical.  So it's going to be a
musical.  We need a song to wrap
the whole story around.  I
decide ed         decided to
structure the story like a pop
song itself, like verse, chorus,
bridge, and this is a little
chart that I handed over to the
composures            composures
at Pollen music to explain that
.  I don't know how clear it
exactly is   is, but it was to
guide them through this s
tructure and idea how that song
would be made.
So J.J. wase er and Alex
Alexis Heart wrote the song, no
way home, and it was performed
by Kelly Schultz and Nicky
bloom.  Pearl is out there in
the world right now.  You could
pull out your phone and watch it
on YouTube, but the song being
such a core, central part of the
story, I figured it would be
really cool for I/O to actually
bring Kelly and Nicky here and d
o it live for all you guys here
and for the world.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Hello.
>> So enjoy The Wrong
Way Home.
.
>>
ÔÖź I hope you stand straight and
tall.  These are fragile times.
We blurred the lines.  The
unlikely iest of places, we all
find a little grace.  There's no
wrong way home.
ÔÖź the spiral shell, the golden
mean.  You see you're just the s
um of those who have been down
this road before.  You were
expecting more.  It won't hurt
to rest a while.  The soft
shoulder by your side.  It ain't
where you've been
ÔÖź There's no wrong way home ÔÖź
(Applause)
>> There is no way to finish
that, so we're just going to say
thanks, and we'll see you next
year at I/O. Thank you, guys.
All of you.
ÔÖź
Google I/O
Configuring the World: Rapid
Actioning Based on Analytic
Insights
May 20,
11:00 a.m. PT
Francesco, one of the
engineering leads for Firebase,
and I'm here with project
manager Safa to introduce a new
service in the Firebase family.
By now, I think you know what
Firebase is. It's a
cross-platform mobile back end
sweet       suite of services
that helps you develop an app,
grow your user base, engage your
users, and earn money. And
Firebase remote config allows
you to instrument your
application so you can run AB
testing of your features.
So, why config? It's a story
that starts many years ago when
I joined a small team that has
this big, ambitious goal in mind
to build an open, mobile,
operating system. Back then, we
wanted something that would
allow us to configure a few
things for different OEMs and
carriers, for example, our all
old system cloud to device
message ing used config to
determine that the period of
heartbeats to connect, based on
carriers in different locations
in the world.
This was so useful that it
grew really, really big. And
when other parts of the company
figured out that this service
existed, a lot of colleagues of
my that were building
applications at Google started
using the system. And at some
point, I think all major Google
app used this service. But usage
wasn't really perfect, because
as
we built the service for the
platform, we didn't have
compartments. So there was cross
-pollination of the
configuration files for
applications.
Each app could read and write
other applications'  s
application's files.
When we built Firebase, we
decide ed it was the right time
to make this service right for
applications, and also for third
party so you could use it. And
we had to do two things. First,
we had to make sure that config
files were for apps. So,
different apps could not be
not edit each other.
Manly     Mainly, it had to
scale. Eight years ago we didn't
predict the success of Android.
Billions of devices, we had to
re-architect the system to make
it scale at the size. And also,
all these applications on top,
we didn't foresee they would use
the service        service. It
was quite a complexity. And
also, because Firebase is cross-
platform, we added iOS devices
and many more applications on
top. But we made it so today we
have Firebase remote config,
which is a console where you
can type values for variables to
instrument your app.
So you can turn on and off
features in your application.
And you can make your code
behave differently. And you can
target devices, a group of
devices, based on language,
carrier, operating system type,
application version, and more.
And you can have multiple of
this in parallel. For each
group, you can select a small
percent of them to get the
initial configuration files, so
you can do stage rollout. That's
important because if you
unleash -- uncover a bug, you
contain the population that is
look     looking at the bug.
And if you want to test
something, you get early feed
back from your users. If you
have a button that says buy, but
you want to try get instead,
you can get early feedback from
your users. And even further, we
connected with Firebase
analytics. So now your A  AB
testing is really powerful,
because you can have a feedback
loop of what works. And you can
target a population based on
your analytics data.
And you can do all this
without repackage ing APQ K,
they don't have to download an
update, it works on the fly,
changing values from the web
console. To get Firebase config
is really simple. You pull in
the Firebase STK, an objective
example, you download the values
when the copcation opens. And
then throughout the code
code, you can use those variable
s to unlock new features. And
the same goes for Android. This
is two slides into one, and the
top part initialization, and
then you play with the variables
.
But let's see in details how
this product works and how we
can control rocket launches. So,
please, welcome, Safa, our
product manager.
>> SAFA ALAI: Thank you.
(Applause)
>> SAFA ALAI: So I'm here
today to do three things. I'm
going to introduce a new term,
wire ing up your app. I'm going
to argue that it pays to always
wire up your app before you
launch. And I'm going to show
you how remote config is a good
solution for this. To do this,
we're going to have a little bit
of fun. Let me introduce you to
rockets express, a pizza
delivery service, inter-planet
planetary, in the solar
system. And, of course, this
service has an app.
And we've packed a whole
bunch of gizmos and features in
this app. Many of them have
never been seen or tried before.
Do I hear you groan already
thinking, oh my God, these are
all going to crash? So, our
whole priority has been to get
this thing launched
launched. So, you know, there's
the pressure. You've probably
experience ed this yourselves.
We're aiming to get to I/O,
after all, and I mean, Jupiter's
I  Io, the moon. And our whole
goal is to get this out there so
we can catch the launch window.
Okay. Our launch goes pretty
well. We shoot right past the
moon. We approach Mars. And our
plan is to go right past Mars,
because we're going to rush to
get to Io. But something
interesting happens now. When we
get to Mars, we spot a bunch of
Martians, and they're having a
pizza emergency over there.
And we realize that they
could use our app to get their
pizza. So our CEO, that's you,
turns up to our engineer and
says, hey, we need to get a
message out to people to show
them how to order pizza with our
app. Unfortunately, Toria
replies saying, sorry, sir. We
were in such a rush to launch
that we didn't wire up our app
in advance. So you ask, what do
we have to do? Okay. Toria says
we were supposed -- we should
have used Firebase remote config
.
And so, the CEO asks, how
much is it going to cost us, how
long is it going to take? And
Toria replies, it's absolutely
free     free. And, it should be
pretty fast. So, we have to go
back to the hangar and wire up.
So the first question is, what
does Toria mean by "wire ing up"
your app? You can think of your
app as this complicate ed
spaceship. It has a lot of
systems, a lot of people working
on it, and, of course, you can
always run down to engineering
every time you need a change or
a corrections,
correction, etc.
But really what you want to
have is a control center. It's a
mission control center like you
see here in Houston. And that
way    way, you can make changes
without relaunching your app
every time. We like to think of
this machine control center as
the remote config console. And
here's the
first screen of a remote config
console before you've entered
any machine control parameters.
And here's a few machine control
parameters in your remote
config console. Except we
actually call these config
parameters.
And as you can see, they
simply consist of key value
pairs. Okay. So, just a few
lines of code, and you see over
here the key is special message.
And you just get the value, not
hard at all to program this.
And here we are, special message
, we are back in the console,
and we're putting into special
message, what we're going to say
to our Martian friends. Okay.
We refitted our app. We came
back. We now have a special
message. And it was important
that we put this behind a config
parameter because maybe by the
time we relaunch and come all
the way back, things have change
ed and we have to say something
a little different.
So this worked out for us,
and we left a bunch of happy
Martian app users now, and grew
our user base. Okay. On to the
next stage of the journey, which
is the asteroid belt. And here
the danger is negative comments
from crashes. And our goal is to
get through the asteroid belt
while minimize ing the negative
comments. Clearly, crashes can
be    be -- and failures -- can
be pretty bad for your app.
Here's some negative comments.
First two are pretty
self-explanatory. The last one
really gets me.
The user likes your app. It's
a good app. They are loyal.
They want to stay with you. And
they're working really hard to
get over tech problems. That's
really sad. What a shame. Okay.
So, after some careful analysis
using Firebase crash, you figure
out that there's one feature
that's bringing
down your whole app. And you
desperately call Toria saying,
owe     oh, no. Thinking, not
saying, oh, no, do we have to go
back? Do we have to go refit
our app? We have to do
everything again?
Fortunately, Toria has been
smart. What she did, what she
realize ed when she refitted the
rocket ship, was that she could
actually go the whole way and
put everything behind a config
parameter. So she put every
feature behind a config
parameter. You can think of
these as feature flags. So,
basically, here's -- one of the
things that helps you do this is
this defaults file that we
have. It allows you to program
lots and lots of features
without actually having to put
them all on the console.
So then, only when you're on
the console do you -- only when
you need to change it do you
change something on the console.
Here's a local default file for
iOS. And here's the same thing
for Android. Again, completely
cross-platform. Everything works
on iOS and Android. And you
fetch the local default files,
surprise, with exactly the same
lines of code. There's no
difference. All that happens is
when you fetch it, the override
value from the console overrides
your local default.
And, we've done a lot of work
to make remote config your
very efficient. So when you
want to get stuff from the
server, for example, you use a
fetch call. The fetch call
checks your local cache --
checks your cache ed values, and
there's a time to live. And it
sees that the time to live has
expire ed. And only when it's
expire ed does it actually go
and fetch stuff. So, that
relieves you of worrying about
how fresh is your stuff. What
you do, you co-fetch anywhere
you wish. And config takes care
of the rest.
Similar things apply to the
rest of the API. Okay. So, now
to turn off a feature, all you
do is you go back to your
console, and its default value
is true, but now you turn it to
false, and that turns off the
feature. So, thanks to Toria's
fore sight,       sight, we
navigate ed our way through the
asteroid belt, while minimize
ing the negative comments
. Okay. Now, we finally approach
our destination
destination, which is Io. A few
interesting facts about Io. I
think you've guessed by now I
like space.
It's the fifth moon of
Jupiter, similar in size to our
moon, and it's got an iron core.
But most importantly of all, it
looks like pizza. I mean, I
could swear, those are olives,
and there's a pepperoni on it.
And trust me, go search on the
internet, and people will say it
looks like pizza. So, then we
have a real problem. Now that
we're getting to Io, we realize
that in a moon that looks like
Peteda        Pete      pizza,
people must know a lot about
pizza.
Are they going to be okay
with the basic pizza, or do we
need to experiment with
something else, like a thick
crust pizza? That's essential.
You, the CEO, goes to Toria and
asks, any chance we can
experiment with thick crust
pizza? To your surprise
surprise, Toria says,
absolutely. How come? Well, when
you wire ed up your app, you
automatically get use of configs
conditions. Now what you can do
is you can apply rules to
select a subgroup of your users.
So here I am showing on the
config console some of the rules
you can use for creating a
condition.
And here it is. I've applied
a specific condition, experiment
one, variant A, to special
message. As you can see, with
this default value, it's basic
pizza. But its experimental
value is special thick crust
pizza. Okay. Let's look a little
bit more closely at two of
these rules, specifically, user
in random        random
percentile, and user in
audience. So, you've probably
gone to a few Firebase
presentations by now, and you
know that Firebase analytics has
a thing called audiences.
Here in this screen, you can
see I'm creating an audience
based on app version. And what
this does is it segments the
user groups to something smaller
so you can target them. And
clearly I'm calling this Io
visitors. And these audiences
are available to Firebase as a
whole, because it's a well-
integrate ed system. So here I
am, you can see that in
conditions for remote config,
itch a         -- I have a
dropdown showing the audiences
available for my app. Here I'm
choose ing Io visitors, which we
just create ed.
But I'd like to also draw
your attention to the little
button on the right, with an
and. And, yes, you guessed it.
It enables me to add another
rule. Over here, I'm adding user
and percentile at 10%. So what
this means is that I took my
audience of Io visitors, and I'm
targeted          targeting 10%
of that audience. Now the same
thing, it's the same exact thing
, no difference, applies to
special message.
Okay. So the next thing is, we
need to actually track this in
Firebase analytics.
How do we do this? Here's a
little tip, one of the things we
can do. You can use user
properties in Firebase analytics
. Here I'm setting up experiment
one. And you set up experiment
one in remote config to reflect
the value of -- to reflect which
experiment is happening. So
here, I have experiment one that
shows you either it's a default
value fire ed, or if the
experiment one variant A spire
ed.         -- fire ed. Then a
couple of lines of code. You get
the value of experiment one out
of config, and you put them
into the user property.
What this does is now every
event that goes to Firebase
analytics is now tagged
with the value of experiment
one, which you can then use in
the analysis by filtering for
the value
of experiment one to see, for
example, if it's variant A. Okay
. So, what's the votes? Is it
going to be basic pizza, or is
it thick crust pizza? I think
the users there were very
sophisticated and they liked
thick crust pizza.
But -- so now we want thick
crust pizza to apply to everyone
. So we go back to remote
config, we get rid of the
condition, and we make the
default value thick crust pizza,
and now everybody gets thick
crust pizza. We did our
experiment, got our results, and
set our default. And as you can
see, they're pretty happy with
their thick crust pizza. Okay.
So now for some real spaceships
out there explore ing the
universe. Here's Fabulous.
It's an app that is incubated
at Duke University Center for
Advance ed Hindsight. And its
purpose is to help you get rid
of bad habits and replace it
with healthy rituals. I'm using
it to improve my own sleeping
habit. You can think of Fabulous
at the ultimate AB testing
platform. Why? Because you're
trying to change user habits.
And user habits are very
difficult to change. So you have
to be able to experiment like
crazy to be able to figure out
what works for these people.
And the Fabulous team has
wire ed up their whole app with
config parameters that they fill
ed in with JSON objects. Here's
an example of one of their AB
testing. It's specifically
interesting because they've
combine ed notifications,
Firebase notifications, with
config. And as you can see at
the top there, there is a
notification showing a little
rocket, very relevant to us, and
a prompt. When you click on
that, the default action is to
take you to the screen that asks
you to set up a full screen
alarm for some activity.
And you can -- you know, you
can choose that and get started.
Interestingly enough, you can
now use Firebase -- they can use
Firebase remote config to
experiment with a   a percentage
of their population, what
happens when they click on a
notification. In this case, when
you click on that notification,
it comes up with something
completely different. It comes
up with a picture of a tree
asking you a question. And if
you answer the question, like,
as -- it's asking you if -- what
does a tree need.
If you answer that it needs
water, it tells you a little bit
about the research. And hope
fully that will have a different
effect on you and cause you to
choose drink water as a good
habit to try out. Here's another
app, Yumly. They are for choose
ing recipes. Now, I have a
personal connection with this,
which is I often have to cook
meals for my daughter. And I
have to admit, cooking is not my
strong suite, all the free food
at Googling. And I actually
struggle often to come up with a
good recipe that she actually
likes.
Well, Yumly helps me out with
dietary preferences, shopping
lists, and everything that goes
with it to help me find a good
meal. So they wanted to
experiment with their Connect
screen. And it's the first
screen that their users see. And
what they wanted to do is find
out how can they improve their
log-in -- how they can improve
their conversion to log-in.
Here's a bunch of parameters,
and a bunch of conditions that
they've set up to test just
that.
Now, one of these tests was
interesting to me. And I'm
showing it to you over here. On
the left, with A, you can see
that they have a generic screen.
And on the right, they have a
contextualize ed screen based on
the user's search, or based on
some other parameter. And so, it
would stand to reason that a
contextual screen would have a
better impact on
log-in, right? Well, wrong.
It's not. It doesn't do that.
They actually ran this
experiment, and they found out
that their generic screen was
much more effective.
In fact, with search, their
generic screen was twice as
effective. And with the recipes,
the generic screen was 20% more
effective. So they went back
and actually got everything back
to generic. And it really goes
to confirm how important it is
to be able to experiment with
stuff before you actually go in
with assumptions. Okay. A few
words on conclusion now
. When you -- many of us, when
we're creating adaptive
-- apps, not only do we want to
run a great business, but we
would really like to go and have
an impact on the world, and
change how people do things. ,
perhaps go further and change
how people think, and perhaps go
even further and change what is
possible.
So, to do this, we have to
have a close conversation with
our users. You can -- with apps,
you really have the potential
to talk to millions of people,
affecting how they think and how
they live, . With the very
greatest apps, and the greatest
conversations
conversations, you can profound
ly shape our culture. To succeed
in this conversation, you need
to instrument your app so that
you can listen to see what users
are up to. And we
know that Firebase analytics
provides you a free and easy
solution
to do so.
But, listening is only half
of this conversation. The other
half is to be able to respond
fast to what users throw your
way. And responding fast is
essential because that way users
can stay engaged, and they can
understand that you're being
responsive, and making changes
that make sense for them. So
we've built Firebase Remote
Config to make it easy to do
just this -- respond fast. It's
got a simple API. It's got a
straightforward console. It
scales massively. And it's
integrated with analytics.
What --    remains for you to
do is to wire up your app
before you launch. So you can
always complete your
conversation with your users.
Here's what you can do next. The
documentation is at fire
fire     firebase.google.com/
remote config. You Can
You can also look at our
support, and at our YouTube and
Twitter feeds. On behalf of
Francesco and myself, thank you
very much for coming today, and
we really look forward to seeing
what you do with Firebase
Remote Config so that we can
actually make it better.
(Applause)
(Session concluded at 11:37
a.m. TP)     PT)
>>
.
May 20, 2016
FB23 best    Best practices
Practices for a great
Great sign-
Sign-in
>>
Welcome!  My name is Seba.  I'm
a UX designer at Google.  I'm
here
today together withal foes
with Alfonzo and John
and I'll talk about online
identity and how to make it
better.  First, what's
what's your name, you taking a
picture?
>> Libby.
>> Hi, I'm Seba. That is pretty
normal, everyday identity
experience.  Just ask somebody
their name, now we know each
other.  Now I can refer to her.
Now I can even make this
presentation better
.
Let's say I have an app with
food.  Libby is trying to use
it.  She'll have is to decide if
she already has an account or
not.  She kind of heard about
the app before, but she's not
sure.  She's tried to sign up
for the app.  So she'll have to
speaker                 have to
enter the e-mail and type two
times her password.  And the
account all right exists.  She
forgot that she already sign up
sometime ago.
So she tries to sign in.  She
types her password that she uses
every day.  Libby, please don't
don't use the same
password always.  It's not safe,
by the way.  Anyway, she tries
and it's not the same password
that she used last time.  And
since Libby is my best client
ever and she's going to keep
pushing to use this app, she's
going through the recovery flow.
So she'll have to type her
user name, check her e-mail, go
click here, and then she'll be
back to reset the password.
She'll type two times again her
password, and success.  The
password, a success.  She tries
to sign in.  Thank you, Libby,
by the way.  You're the best.
So she signs in, types another
password and finally, Libby,
you're in.  She can use my app.
But you never notice that your
you're signing into the
website, not the app, because
the recovery flow is a web flow.
So you have to switch.
Finally, another password, and
you're in.  Thank you, Libby.
You're the best.  Please, for
Libby.
(Applause)
so, as you can see, it's not
very easy for Libby to remember
passwords, even to remember that
she had an account
or how they sign in.  You can
use password and phone numbers.
You can use IDPs.  And it's,
quite frankly, very difficult.
And also, in my -- I'm ashamed
to say this -- 17 years of
experiencing of signing in
websites and apps, I never had
the client asking me or telling
me this:  A magical experience
is going to start by asking
everyone   body to sign up or
pass      type a password.  That
doesn't happen.  It usually
goes, we have this app and this
technology is going to do
going to do do this
and it will be            it
will be awesome and it will be
it will be great and
Libby will love it.  So, yeah,
right, you have to sign in users
.  Oh, yeah, and you have to
sign up to creates
create acts      accounts.
Well, after that it will be
it will be awesome and
it will be            it will be
great and we'll do this and
that.  Blah, blah, blah.
And to be honest, that happens a
lot, and it is how it should be
it should be.  You
should not care about your
system, because it's not your
business, not your core
functionality, but the downside
is that without that nothing
works
.  Here, no one ever said that.
So it's also very difficult for
developers to cover that.  You
have to cover all these cases.
You have to keep it secure all
the time, and you have to cover
all these flat      platforms
that Libby uses, like phone,
watches, computers, blah, blah,
blah.  And it's very difficult.
So we believe that it should be
simpler and should be
should be easier.  Today we're
going to talk about this three
products that we're working on
to make that thing happen.
John.
>> JOHN HJELMSTAD: Thanks,
Seba.  I'm John.  I'm the lead
on the identity platform.  If
you went to the Chrome web
security talk yesterday, one of
the interesting details you
might have learned is that the
top password
in 2015:123456.  It's follows
ed very quickly by the number
two, which is 78.  And if you
look at the top 20 passwords,
you'll see six of the top 20 are
actually number sequences
between one and four and one and
nine.  Most of the rest of them
are character sequences
straight down the line as well.
QRTY, things like this.  There
are two ways we can look at this
.  One is a problem statement
that we talk about a lot of the
time.  This is a huge problem
when people secure their lives,
online communication, their
payments information, their
financial information and so on
online.
I think that's been pretty well
documented.  The other way we
can view this is as an
opportunity.  That's what we see
with identity platform as well.
The opportunity is engendered
in the fact that the salient
feature of them not that they're
bad, it's that they're simple.
Users demand that degree of
simplicity.  It's our challenge
as the developer community
overall to present an equally
simple user experience that
increases the user security.
That's the theme underlying our
work with Google sign-in
sign-in in the last year.
Google sign-in         sign-in
is a product we're familiar with
helping users sign in to their
account or your website.  To
help similar me
simplify this in the last year,
I'm sure everybody has seen a
consent screen, which is the
first thing you see when you
type Google sign-in
sign-in.  It's a wall of text.
A bunch of stuff to read and
understand.  You might ask
yourself what actually am I
sharing with this site?  Does
the site even really need it?
Are they going to spam me?  What
actually is here.  It's not
especially clear.
Every moment that the user
pauses to consider any of these
questions is a moment they could
bail out of your app to begin
with.  Not everybody is quite as
persistent as Libby.  What did
we do to help counter this?  We
created the account trip UI.
Based account trip UI shows
exactly the information that
will be shared with the web
side
.
The core nlveth
information we found, photo URL,
name, and e-mail address.  It's
just that simple.  Let's take a
look at what it looks
like with doodle      Doodle.
At that point the information,
and you're in.  Doodle can sign
you in or sign you up using that
information pretty straight
forwardly.
I'm happy to announce that while
we released account chip for
Android during last Google I/O,
we'll be rolling it out on web
and IOS finally so you have the
same experience no matter which
platform you start on.  That's
only half the experience.  We
also wanted to work to simplify
the integration password for
developers and make it faster
and more robust.  We did so by
folk go all of our STKs around
the concept of ID tokens.  ID
tokens are JSON web tokens,
which includes a bunch of
information, including the
profile information that I just
mentioned to you of        you
before.  That's partnered with a
cryptographically signature,
verify identified using
libraries open source as well as
provided as part of Firebase
authentication, service side SDK
.
To illustrate how this helped
simplify for your site, let's
talk about the old flow.  This
is the old flow wherein you call
the sign-in API and you'll get
an access tunneling
token or code, either you'll be
having to send to your app back
in.  If it's a code you exchange
it for an access token.  In
either case, you have an app
back in that user info call to
the identity providers and
actually get the user
information that you translate
into an account record.
Now, this is a live -- this is
important to note this is a live
call that happens while the
user is signing in, so it has
latency.  A bunch of things can
go wrong.  It's not standardized
either over identity providers.
So you need to implement
custom code to be able to pull
the stuff apart       apart,
actually get the information you
need, name, e-mail address, and
so on, and translate that into
user record, which is
represented as a cookie or
session info.
Now, as developers we know that
less is more.  And any complex
at this is bad complexity due to
Murphy's  's law.  Anything
that can go wrong will Peopling
wrong
wrong will go wrong.  We have to
make a request to the get info
endpoint          endpoint and
figure out what the information
is and return it.  Let's take a
look at what the ID toke
especially looks like.  Now you
call the sign-in SDK.  In
response you'll get an ID token.
That can be             That
can be sent to your app back end
and be decoded by verifying its
significant                 its
signature.  Once it's verified,
it can be trusted.  That
information contains all the
basic profile information we
included before, which can be
used to translate into a account
record on your back end, as
simple as that.
Take a look at what this looks
like on the client as well as
the server side.  On the client,
you'll notice here on Android,
as an example, that our default
setting is now simply just to
request basically profile
information.  You build a goal
API client.  You Google
Google
API client.  You you'll be able
to pull up the ID token, just as
simple as that.
Now, the Firebase authentication
server side SDK has been
launched with the rest of the
Firebase authentication product,
which we announced two days ago
.  It expose an API that you can
see right here called verify ID
token, which does all the heavy
lifting of decode ing the token
, verifying the token and the
security checks.  Once the token
has been decoded, it tans all
the information that you need.
Contains
contains
all the information that you
need. .
Java discrepancy looks
same.  We support no. JS, which
exposes the same method, verify
ID
JavaScript looks very much the
same.  We support no. JS, which
exposes the same method, verify
ID token.  In its response,
you'll have      have all the
information you need.  So much
as          As much as we love
Google sign-in         sign-in,
and I do, there are a number of
bass      password accounts as
well.  Identity platforms helps
improve, for that I introduce
Stevenson he have
Stephen Soneff.
(Applause)
>> STEVEN SONEFF: My name is
Stephen.  I'm the product
manager on the Google identity
platform.  Today we'll talk
about what happens next.  So
once you've taken John's  's
advice and you've added a Google
sign-in         sign-in button
on your app, you have a sign-in
a sign-in strewn
a sign-in screen
that looks like that.  Let's see
what happens to Libby.  There
are a few buttons at the top,
and you have to remember which
one it is that you picked last
time and have to sort out what
will happen if you pick a
different button next time.
There's still problems of all
those legacy existing users who
have a user name and pass
worried                  and
password.  There is the problem
of sign-in         sign-in and
sign-up UFI and the confusion
between them.  It gets worse
when you get to mobile.  It
could be             It could be
really painful.
So all of these pieces add up.
In studies that we've done and
industry research that we've
looked at, we find that nearly
half of people who see a sign-up
or sign-in         sign-in
screen don't       don't
actually complete the action
successfully.  This can range
from all manner of things, from
picking the wrong button and
getting into a confusing
situation to remembering --
having to remember your password
and recover it, to being
confused about trying to create
an account when one already
exists.  Probably an experience
that you've seen yourself.  So
if you put all these little
pieces together, it can be a
really major drop-off in the
users that you see to your app,
that if potentially half of the
users who are trying to complete
a transaction or sign up or
subscribe to your app are
dropping off in one of these
flows, that's as many as twice
as many users you could have if
you smooth these flows out.
That's what we will take a look
at today.  The Smartlock set of
API he is           APIs can
assist the user, make it easy to
create an account to sign up,
or to be able to sign back in
automatically.
Now, we launched Google
Smartlock on Android last year.
Some of the new things we'll
talk about this year are the
ability to automatically sign in
in the web in Chrome, new APIs
that we assist in signing up.
Most importantly, I think what
we really want to look at is
some of the great implementation
s that partner apps, developers
many of whom are in the audience
have done, and the great
performance they have seen.
Let's do a quick recap of the
main pieces of functionality
that the Smartlock provides.
Majeure at I/O and
Imagine you're in line
in I/O, you pull out the ticket.
Here is ticket master.  And
instead of having to remember
your user name and password, the
app simply shows you this blue
car and your ticket right away.
There is no fumbling, having to
recover your account while
everyone is waiting in line
behind you.  Probably reduces
the stress a lot when you're in
a tight situation.
So that's really nice to be able
to sign people in automatically
.  It would be             It
would be even better if we could
do it on the web.  So let's
walk through an example here
with HRS.  This is a hotel
reservation app that Google
actually uses for our own
reservations.  I'm happy to see
this available on the web.  If
you start in the native app here
, you can create an account, do
some searches, basically set up
your entire itinerary and you're
offered to save that password
or save the account that you've
used if you've logged in with
Facebook or Google.  The idea is
once you visit the website,
maybe this is where you want to
complete your transaction, where
you're entering credit card
information, for example, you
can visit the site.  And instead
of having to find that log in
button and to remember to be
logged in, you'll simply be
automatically signed in.  This
is live on the web right now.
You recollect               You
can try this on HRS and we have
Alibaba's  's express an, ringed
's express
an, linked
's express an, Linde
's express
an, Linked  ed-In.
It's pretty straight forward.
You can do this purely with a
client side change with your app
or the front end of your
website.  So when you need to
get somebody signed in, perhaps
when your app is starting is
what our recommendation is, you
construct a credential request.
So credential request has a few
properties.  You basically
specify what types of reshales
you can                     of
credentials you can support,
like user name, passwords, or
pointer, and say this person is
signed in with Google or
Facebook and you need to get a
token to awe     authenticate
this user.  You pass it to our
request API, and then you get
called back.  You get called
back with any results that are
available or you can just
proceed to a normal sign-in
sign-in if there is nothing.
So if you get something back,
you can look at what you've got.
It will have the identifier,
so the user name or the e-mail
address or maybe even a phone
that you've saved previously or
the user has opted in to save in
Chrome.  And then it comes with
it an account type.  So if it's
a Facebook sign-in
sign-in, you can look at that
and say I need to talk to
Facebook.  Or if it's the
password, you can take that
password, submit it on behalf of
the user as though she     they
typed it in themselves, set up
a          set up a session.  At
that point you have an
authenticated user.  You can
show them the relevant signed in
content right away, as soon as
they open the app.  And that's
really valuable, because if we
look at some examples here, one
on the web that I think is worth
calling out in a second is the
guardian, where calling this
request API in Chrome, they can
do the same thing -- have
someone who is a web user
automatically signed in.  And
it's very valuable for them that
they now have this huge bump in
cross-device signed in usage.
You can imagine for apps like
the guardian        Guardian, or
the New York Times, when we
showed last year, how valuable
this is to have signed in users
across your platforms as a
publisher to be able to do cross
-device analytics to keep users
signed in, show them relevant
content, maintain their
subscription information without
having to provide the support
around getting signed back in or
recovering from forgotten
accounts.
So that's the automatic sign-in
sign-in functionally.
To get there, we should take a
closer look at how this
information is saved.  I'll show
an example here in a second.  I
really want to call that out,
and that's saving nonpassword
information.  First, looking at
an app like sky scanner the
traditional flow is you enter
the password, get the same
dialogue.  We have seen all the
apps that implement this a 65%
save rate, about two in three
users will opt in to save this
information.  Those users can
then be automatically signed in.
like now without a password.  If
you're liking, contribution
for example, the
Facebook button, agreeing to the
consent, and getting a token
from Facebook.  New York Times
will offer, and you can try this
in the live app right now,
offer to save the account.  What
it's doing here instead of
saving a user name and password,
you're saving user name and a
string that says "with
Facebook."  You know what to
look for next time.  When we
come back, you'll see the apple
open.  This is a brand
app
will open, the blue bar shows,
sign you in, and you never even
had to see the login screen.
So let's take a look at how
that's implemented.  In this
case you'll create a credential
object that you need to save.
You can see the two variations
here.  On the top, you create a
user name and password account,
or if it's a nonpassword account
, you can set other eyes
types of user names.  For
example, an e-mail address
orphan, and then
or phone number
phone number and set
the type, whether it's with
Facebook or Google or some other
type that you support, like
phone numbers.
Then you pass the credential
object into the save API.
You'll get called back with a
result.  The result is either
successful, if we can update an
existing credential or
automatically save a nonpassword
credential, for example, to
Google account for Google
sign-in         sign-in, or if
you need to show a dialogue to
have the user interact and opt
in to save.
On the web, it's very similar.
You construct the reden shale
object                    re
credential object.  If you'd
like more information on this,
you might have seen the talk
from the Chrome team yesterday
about how to save all types of
information, how to handle the
responses that come back, submit
forms, or handle federated
credentials to make automatic
sign-in         sign-in on the
web possible.
To look at some of the really
impressive performance numbers
we have seen in the last year.
We have Netflix, one of our big
launch partners from last year,
whose growth has been really
impressive over the last year
expanding to new markets.  They
have a lot more people using
their app.  To be able
To be to          To be
able to automatically sign in,
they've been seeing less
inquiries around forgot even
prison records, but their
forgotten prison records.
This cannen    be a huge money
savings if you have a sizable
support system right now and
it's a subscription or pay-based
service where people will
definitely contact you if they
can't get in.
So the last big piece I want to
talk about here is how to make
sign-up easier.  This is a new
API, the ability to get, as we
call, a hint, to show a dialogue
that looks like this with
previously used e-mail addresses
, with accounts that are on the
device.  And pie showing this
dialogue first
And by
showing this dialogue first,
there are some unusual
interactions.  From the Z.
>> #03: Llow
Zillow app first, it allows the
user to intelligently sign in
or remind you they need to use
Facebook or Google to log in
because they don't       don't
have a password.  Eve
They've even gone so far to
as offering to create an account
without a password, one tab
account password.
For example, let's play the
video.  And we'll see the
assisted sign up experience.  We
have Alibaba's  's express app,
user rental        registering
with e-mail.  It allows the user
to one at that point fill the
name, the e-mail address, and
then just have to create the
password.  That's purely a
client-side he    addition.
Without doing complex rework or
big back end changes, they were
able to assist the user to fill
in three-quarters of the
information.  They have more
people successful little
completing the sign-up flow with
just that little client-side
change.  In fact, we can even
move forward while the other
person isn't       isn't even
finished yet, and see what the
implementation work that's
involved here is.  It's pretty
simple.  So I think this is
perhaps one of the highest ROI
investments that you could make
in your app.  One of the best
learnings you could take out of
I/O is adding a few lines of
code, assisting sign-up.  You
can see much better completion
of the account registration
flows.
So to make it happen, you
construct a hint request, as we
say.  Up specify what type of
fires               type of
identifiers you would like to
see.  You pass that in the "and
you get                     in
the API.  You see the sign-in
sign-in flow if you've
merged the two together, then
you have the opportunity to show
them, have them pick an entry,
and you'll get called back on
activity result with the
information.  It's the name,
e-mail address.  It's even more
importantly something like an ID
tone            an ID token, a
verified e-mail address to skip
things like e-mail verification.
here.  Linked infrastructure ran
Linked inused
Linked in used this, and even
reports from other oops, like
Camu      Camut, which might be
in the audience, 20% higher
conversion on sign-up.  To find
out more about the partners
check out this link.  The last
shoutout is we  We go  Go, a
travel app from Singapore.  They
have taken account registration
out of the little men you'll in
the corner and put it into one
it into one of
their primary flows with one tap
and seeing a huge increase in
user registrations.
We hope to see your app up here.
Maybe you'll be up here next
year.
I'd like to hand it over to
Alfonzo, but building a new one
with Firebase
.
(Applause)
>> ALFONSO GOMEZ-JORDANA: Thank
you.  My name is Alfonso and
I'm the project manager.  Not
long ago, I was an application
developer.  As I'm sure many of
you are today in the audience.
I remember spending sleepless
nice fighting with the
authentication system of my
applications.  Some of the
problems that John, Stephen, and
Sebastian mentioned today I
kind of relate to.  The biggest
problem I had with awe tentation
s                           I
had with authentication was I
never knew if I was properly
securing my user's  's
information.  I remember
spending lots of time
integrating with third party or
OS protocols and all this other
stuff.  I never got to manage my
user sessions in an effective
way.  The third lining
thing is authentication is hard.
That is something I didn't
care that much about.   .
When you're doing your own
authentication system, you'll
look through some steps that go
more or less like the picture.
You will begin by setting up
your authentication back end and
you authorize your users in
your own back end resources.
When setting People        up
your back end, you want to make
sure it's secure.  If not, your
user's  's data may get
compromised.  Second, it has to
be up all the time.  If not,
your application will probably
go down with
it.
Handling user's  's credentials
is tricky.  You have to
integrate with off flow or if
you handle prison records
handle
passwords, and you have to
handle the cases where your
users forget their credentials.
In managing user sessions, you
want to do this effectively.
You want to ensure your sessions
are long-lived so users don't
don't have to sign in
every few days when they come
back to your application, but at
the same time if your user's
's device is stolen, you want to
ensure that their session is
revoked.
Finally, when you I meant
mrementd all of that
implemented all that, you have
to take the authentication of
the user and do something useful
with it in the back end.  In
general, all of these steps are
pretty involved.  And I'm pretty
sure in most of the cases this
is not the core business of your
application.  You want to focus
on other things, such as making
your application awesome for
your users
.   .
Firebase authentication aims to
make all of these problems easy
for you.  In the next three
minutes I'm going to show you
how you can get or    very east
lip your users signed
very easily your users signed
into the code and no deep
understanding of thousand
authentication works.  In this
year's  's I/O we released a
revamped set of APIs, some
exciting new functionality, and
built on top of a Google
infrastructure.  Let's see what
Firebase offers.  Some of you
may have seen this picture
before, this is one of our color
data centers at Google.
Firebase services are cloud
services that run an
infrastructure like the one
pictured in the picture here.
Google takes care of making sure
that the services are with
reliable and available for your
application.  The only thing you
need to do       to do is
implement against the client two
user services.
With Firebase you can get your
user sign-in         sign-in
using a wide range of options, .
From Google sign-in
sign-in to Facebook login or
your own e-mail and password
accounts.  Doing so is very easy
.  This is using web and
JavaScript where we either
create or signing a user using
e-mail and password credentials.
The first line of code here
does all of the following.
Let's see if I get it right.  It
gets the e-mail and password as
a user and sends it to a secure
channel up to our back end.
There it performs integrity
checks and ensures the password
is strong enough.  It makes sure
there is no pre-existing user.
It creates a user record or
user database.  It met a pair of
tokens, sends them through a
secure channel back to the
device and then persists into
the client application.  With
that you have the user sign-in
sign-in.
The important thing here is you
can forget I think
everything that I just mentioned
, because all of that have is
done by Firebase.  The only
thing you need to learn is these
two lines of code.  That's much
more simple.
Now support through identity
providers, such as Facebook.
The first thing you need to do
to do is go to a Firebase
console, which is very easy to
use, and enable them.  What
Once you've got that, you're
ready to write some
code.  And we're taking a
Facebook access token and
signing a user application.  The
second line of code here in the
bottom is something very
similar is    as what they
mentioned before.  It's second
It's sending it to
a secure channel through the
back end.  It's making sure the
token hasn't been tampered with,
hasn't been expired, makes sure
the audience is correct, making
sure non     someone is not
trying to hack you.  It creates
a user act     account in the
database.  A pair of tokens with
your user session information,
and finally your user is signed
in.  Once again, the only thing
you need to learn are these two
lines of code.  Very simple
.   .
Okay.  So let's say you've got
some users signed in.  Next
thing you want to do       to do
is you want to make sure that
this is actually working.  For
that reason, especially the
console of users that you can
access, the Firebase console,
which is especially the sign for
those initial steps when you're
starting to build your
authentication system and want
to see your accounts ans they're
being created
as                           s
they're being created.
Let's pause a second and look at
some of the information that
you can see here.  If you look
at the right, you see the user
ID.  In Firebase every time one
of our users signed  s in for
the first time, we create a
unique user ID that identifies
them across the whole
application.  Also, take a look
at the second column, which is
called providers.  In that
column you will see can which
sign-in         sign-in
mechanism the user has signed
in.  In this year's  's version
of Firebase that's new, now your
users can have more than one
sign-in         sign-in for that
account.  Very useful if you
want to allow your users to sign
in one day with Twitter and
later on with the password and
e-mail account.  They can access
with either of those mechanisms
.
Okay.  So we have the user
signed in.  Now we have to do
to do something useful
with them.  This in my opinion
the                        This
snippet of code is from Java.
We're detecting when the user is
signed in and special eyes go
the experience
in and
personalizing it.  On the
authentication of the
application and once the event
is triggered, you react to the
change in the sign-in
sign-in state to update your
application.  In this case, for
example, we personalize the user
interface application by using
the display that I am that
that comes from the signed in
user.  This is useful.  You can
make the application feel better
for your user.  But the most
compelling use case of
authentication is actually
authorizing into your own back
end resources services.
That is also very easy with
Firebase.  This diagram more or
less explains the steps you want
to take if you want to do
to do this.  First, your user
signs into an application.  Then
you ex-Strathmore the
extract the token
with one line with the clients
and it's signed, so you can
trust it.  Then you send that
token up to your server and you
use one of the server to
validate the integrity of the
token and with this you can
really tell that the user is
calling your application is who
they came to be.  Once you've
got that up in your server, then
you have to apply your own
authorization logic to give
access to your own resources.
simpler if you had to implement
it on your own.  But still, it
does require a little bit of
planning and you have to
implement your authorization log
on the back end.  We can make
this even simpler.  As you know,
fire pace service
Firebase services worked
better together.  If you use
Firebase storage or Firebase at
that time for storing the
database, all the planning,
sending the token up to the back
end and performing the
authorization logic is done
automatically for you.  The only
thing you need to do       to
do, you need to write the
clarity of rules which specified
this user can acts as this
resource.  No ding         No
single line of code, neither the
clients or the back end, to
make this happen.  Massively Kim
simplified compared to if
you had to implement this on
your own.
So let's do a quick recap.  It's
a managed authentication back
end which we offer six different
sign-in methods.  We have
client as the case for Android,
IOS and web, and we else for
game developers out there.  We
have servers that token
verification and token mint go
and       ing and Java.  And we
have a concept for user setup
and management.  There is many
more functionalities that I
couldn't            I couldn't
cover today.  You can check out
in our website, in our samples,
and YouTube videos.
So we took Firebase
authentication and with you
actually went there and spoke
with different startsups that
they were either building their
identification system for the
first time or they weren't happy
with theirs and they wanted to
replace it.  Here are some of
the things they built and some
of the things they told us
.
Build it in almost two days.  It
took them two weeks to build
this beautiful application, and
for authentication they used
Firebase authentication with
Facebook and Google.  It took
them literally an often to build
it.  It was production red
after that.
Qu
Quav
Quaver
Quaver, a music application app,
they really liked the fact that
you can link multiple --
multiple credentials to the same
account.  Check out their
application for that.  It's
really good.
Then also existing applications
implemented for the first time
or modified their existing
authentication system and they
all called out using Firebase.
With Firebase authorization
entication we tried to
make sign-in         sign-in
experience as easy as possible
for you.  So you can forget of
all the details of how
authentication works and just
focus the experience for your
users.  With that, I'm going to
leave it to John to do a quick
recap and maybe show us a little
.
(Applause) Johns Johns
>> JOHN HJELMSTAD: We have seen
it's very easy to build a full
on stack on top of that.  We're
pretty much done.  Unfortunately
, we still need to do       to
do a bunch of additional work.
In particular, this talk is
called best practices for a
reason.  We've talked about a
number of different tools and
techniques to help users get
signed in really efficiently,
securely, and quickly.  So let's
all put that together into an
app which can't be too difficult
; right?  So let's start out.
For the purposes of discussion,
let's say people understand user
name and password flows, so we
create one of these things in
our actual app.  We wire it up
to Firebase authentication, no
big deal.  It's not quite
complete, because we need to be
able to create a sign up flow.
We determine the difference
between existing account and a
new account.  From that, we
either fork to the account
creation flow or the sign-in
sign-in flow.  We're
thinking to ourselves we're
getting closer to ship ability,
but not really, because we know
from personal experiences and an
I can              and antidote
s from our users, we'll
people will forget their
passwords.  As we talked at the
beginning of the discussion, to
up level security in general and
increase similar police
plicity and usability for
our users, we want to implement
Google sign-in         sign-in.
Maybe they're familiar with
other signers.  There is quite a
bit of client logic getting
involved in the mix here.  We
have introduced another problem.
I might have signed in to this
particular application using my
Google account, get my Facebook
account has the same e-mail
address associated with it.
That's really confusing.  We do
not want to create a duplicate
account in this case.  We need
to implement account linking
logic where we have a matching
fire      identifier, direct the
mechanism that they used in to
sign in before or link a new
prior to that same account.  The
back end provides this for us.
As we can see there is quite a
bit of client logic.  Now we're
done.
We're not quite done.  Stephen
mentioned earlier today there is
a number of things that
Smartlock for passwords can help
get your users in the door.
Automatically signing them in,
easily        easing the sign-in
sign-in process.  This
is a one time cost, out the door
, we're completely finished;
right?  Well, once again, not
quite.  In the modern age we
need to do       to do it two
more times at least.  Web and
IOS, as well as Android there
are all equally important
.  Let's toss in a web
implementation and IOS
implementation.  Simple; right?
No big deal.  So we happen to
know that it's quite complex,
because we put all this together
ourselves.  And we had to keep
it updated in good working order
over time as well.
The lines of code we found that
it took to implement these
entire flows for web IOS and
Android number in the thousands,
up to 16,000        16,000
lines of code to manage and
maintain all the logic that we
just mentioned, so long as you
support all the functionality
that we just supported or that
we just described, which is not
always required, but something
we definitely remember
recommend.  What's        What's
the better solution?  We have
Firebase UI authentication.  It
is a full stack of UI elements
that implement the entire flows
we just mentioned for you on web
, IOS, and Android, and only a
handful of lines of code to
implement the flows exactly as
described in the chart.
Let's take a look at what some
of this actually looks like.
(Applause)
other environments, the pattern
is very much the same.  Create
an off UI object, configure it
with the providers and other
information that you want, and
then tis play the UI.  Wire up
your results, you get the user
object or an error code.  Here
on Android you can see that
we're doing that for e-mail,
Facebook, and Google, and a
nonactivity result will get a
success status indicating the
user is signed in from which we
can obtain a user object if we
want to or transition to
assigned in state
IOS is very much the same.
Create an off UI object.  Set
your providers, terms of service
URL, then from that generate an
off view controller.  You can
use that as your root view
controller or on top of your
existing root view controller.
You get the results.
Web, no surprise, is very much
the same as well.  Configure
other providers that you want,
and then configure a call backs
for sign-in             for
sign-in success scpels      as
well as show the UI
That's not quite all, because we
know that even though a couple
lines of code to implement
effing I just showed to you, we
want to make sure everything
I just showed to you, we want
to make sure that the Firebase
UI is customizable as well.
Basic theming, as you can see to
get you out of the door in a
line or two of code.  But on a
platform by platform basis, we
support a number of different
types of customization as well.
In particular, on Android, you
can update -- you can override
strings. .XML files or label. .X
ML files to lay out details in
your application.
On IOS we offer subclass go
model for the home screen
ing
model for the home screen so
you are         you can argue
arbitrarily do that as
well.  On web, it's such that
the surrounding context can show
whatever branding, colors, and
so on that you like.
This is still early days and we
are working on additional
customization mechanisms as well
.  I'm happy to report today as
well this entire implementation
on IOS and Android is open
sourced and will be open
sourcing the web implement as
well.  You can inspect all the
code you like, as well as
downloading it, integrating it
into your application,
customizing it all that you like
.  Please do submit bug reports,
feature requests and so on.
We also have a web repositive
Terry with the same URL suffix
with-web for reports and bug mix
es.  We do plan on open sourcing
the implement awing there.
Firebase UI authentication,
straight out of the
box
ation
there.
Firebase UI authentication,
straight out of the box that we
have learned over the source
course of years at
Google and we continue to find
the support in a further fashion
as well.
As more identity technologies
come out the door and more
innovations keep getting added.
We offer simple customization
as well as arbitrary
customization by open source and
you can inspect the code all
that you like.
Let's recap all of that
what we just talked about today.
If you're an existing
developer, Google sign-in
sign-in is a great way to
securely up-level your user
security by allowing them to use
their Google account to get
into your app or website.
Smartlock for passwords helps
them to remember how they got in
the door to begin with, whether
the existing password or using
a fed rated identity provider.
It also helps grease the wheels
on your sign up flow and reduce
your support costs.
Finally, Firebase authentication
is a full hosted authentication
solution paired with UI that
helps get your and get you from
zero to app in record time in
just a few lines of
code.
couple of apps to get you
started, click through and take
a look, a couple of links.
Thanks for taking the time.  We
really appreciate you coming out
.
(Applause)
if you have any questions,
we're going to be at the doors
over at the left afterward, as
well as in the office hours
areas.  Thanks.
fireside Chat:  Firebase in the
Real World.
Real World.Fireside Chat:
Firebase in the Real World.
May
20th.
Fireside Chat:  Firebase in the
Real World.
May 20th.
FB15.
16.
have some bad news.  The bad
news, Google I/O is almost over,
we'll go back to our daily
lives soon.  The good news,
there is enough time for me to
tell you a bit more about
progressive web apps.   That's
not -- that slide doesn't do it
for me!  There is enough time
for me to tell you about
progressive web apps!  Yeah!
>> I'm really excited about
progressive web apps, I love the
web.  The web is the biggest
most important
platform, you publish your idea
to a super low barrier to
entry.  Mobile is very
important.  And the Web Ex
importance on mobile, it hasn't
always been great.  Progressive
web apps are here to bridge the
gap between where we wish mobile
web was and where it is.
You may have heard a lot of
things about progressive web
apps, all of the technologies in
it, all of the different things
that make it up, but really
progressive web apps boil down
to two key ideas:  You need a
first class mobile experience
for your site, that means that
if I'm looking at a site on a
phone it feels like it belongs
on that phone and it has nice
big touch targets, it feels like
it belongs on the system.
The other thing that's kind of
unique to Progressive Web Apps
and is available, you need a
first class connectivity
experience.  If I'm at home on
blazing fast wi-fi power
powered by Google Fiber, in a
subway, no access at all, I
should be able to get access
from the web applications.
That's not been possible for a
long time.
Really, progressive web apps, it
is not a separate thing, a
separate system we're buying
into, before I built web apps
but now progressive web apps!
They're now a new set of
practices and technologies that
help us build good web apps.  Of
course picking technologies for
building web apps is pretty
hard.  There is a ton of things
out there, hard to know what to
pick, who to use, why picking
this stack over another stack
and as you may notice from my
shirt, I'm a fan of Firebase.
Firebase is an integrated suite
of products helping you develop
your applications,   grow your
user base and earn more money.
For web applications Firebase
saves you a lot of time and
hassle of choosing what's the
right way to do X or the correct
thing to do for Y.
Let's say that I have an idea, I
want to build the world's first
100% emoji powered team
collaborated app.  I'm excited
about it.  I go to Jake and talk
about service workers and
realize it is the world's second
100% emoji powered team
collaboration app.  I need to
move quickly.  I have to build
something, get it out there so
that they don't run away with
all of the users I want!  I may
integrate with Firebase so that
users can sign in with Google ,
gethad you been, Twitter
credentials and get in the app
quickly.  I need a place for the
application data.  I'll use the
Firebase realtime database, no
matter the client, whenever any
user changes data in my system
it is instantly synced to all
other connected devices without
me having to write complex
pulling logic, anything else.
Firebase op and database make it
easy to build powerful web
applications.
I need a place to put that
application.  I may want to
deploy it to Firebase hosting.
It is a static web hosting
service that let's you deploy
your site to a global CDN with a
simple command line
implication.  It takes a few
seconds and it is really easy to
get started.
Now I have   built my web app.
I have an idea of what I'm
doing.  I have deployed it to
Firebase hosting.  Let's look at
the web app.
This is --
oh.
I need to start a web server
here.  This is a simple web
application build with Firebase
and polymer, Google'S library
for web components and you can
put it in the integrations.
I'll refresh.  You see this.  I
will sign in with Google With
teamoji.
The demo Gods are against me.
That's all right.
Here we go.
I have signed in with Google .
As you see, I have the team
status updates and I can update
things.  Since I have had two
demo failures I'm feeling
nervous right now.  I want to
let my team know that.  I can
create a new team.
Let's make a Google I/O team
here.
All right.  I have made my
Google I/O team.  I'm feeling a
bit better, it hasn't had
another train wreck yet.
This is my application.  You
know, it worked well.  If I'm a
web user, I access this, whether
it is in a browser simulating a
mobile device, on a real mobile
device, it will be a good
experience.  What happens if I
go offline?  That's not a great
user experience.  In fact,
that's not any user experience.
My app is completely gone.
You may have heard a lot about
offline first with regard to
progressive web apps, that's not
the only important thing.
Believe it or not, connectivity,
it is pretty good in a lot of
places -- or at least good
enough.   You're not going to be
offline much of the time.
There may be a significant
portion of the time that you
don't have the best
connectivity.
Let's say I have just is a
regular 3G connection.  I want
to load my teamoji app.  I'm
going to vamp a bit.  This takes
a long time actually.
Low connectivity and web
applications traditionally have
not mixed well.  That was 10, 15
seconds to load the web
application and that's not
really acceptable to my users.
If I hit that every time I want
to go update my status, no one
will adopt my application.  We
need to use new technologies to
make this a better experience.
Right now I have my web
application, there is nothing
wrong with existing web
applications and existing
technology.  If I have a good
Internet connection I can build
a web app that leaves my user
feeling really happy much of the
time.  We can do more.  We can
integrate our web application
with the platform a little
better so that I get things like
a nice icon on my home screen
or a splash screen when I'm
loading.  Now users feel more
like this is designed for
mobile, this is something that I
can use.
We can go even further and cash
have the bare bones and
the application, they're ready
instantly when we boost the web
application.  Now users are
really happy.  That's what they
want!  They want the app to be
fast, they want it to work where
they go and we can take it a
step further and make the
application data offline so even
if they have no connectivity at
all they can use the
application.  That makes them so
happy they turn into a cat for
some
reason!
I'm talking about progressive
web apps and something I want to
emphasize, that progressive web
apps, believe $or not, they're
built progressively.  This is
not all or nothing.  You don't
have want to do everything I'm
talking about here today all at
once and, you know, spend months
developing it and then do a big
bang launch.  Each technology
can be implemented one by one
adding new features to the web
applications, making it a better
experience on mobile and making
your users more happy because
that's what it is all about.
You know, forget what I said
earlier,   progressive web apps
are not a way to build good web
apps, we can do that.
Progressive web apps is a way to
build great web apps.
How do we achieve that
greatness?  Where do we go to
get from where we are today to a
great progressive web apps that
works in all of these
situations?  Something that I
want to sort of emphasize and
remind you, users don't care
what technology stack you use to
build your application.   They
don't care what framework you
choose, they don't care even
whether this a native or a
mobile app.  For users, if it
looks like an app, if it feels
like a an app, it is an app!
That's all there is to it.  They
want a good experience.
What we're going to do today,
we'll take this teamoji app and
add better experiences so it
becomes a first class mobile
application.
The first thing we'll do, it is
easy, we'll add a web app
manifest to the application.  A
web app manifest is just a new
standard that allows you to
provide some data about your
application so that browsers and
operating systems can pick that
up and use it for various hints
on how to work.
Here is what it looks like.  We
have the object, we have a name,
a short name, so the short name
is used under an application
icon on the home screen, the
name may be used on the splash
screen as it launches.
We have a theme, background
color.  Want theme color, going
to the title bar on Android when
in the task switcher.   The
background color is going to be
the background of your splash
screen as the application
launches.
We have some configuration about
dig play          display and
orientation.When I launch the
app, how do I want it to feel?
Stand alone is the closest
analogue to standard native
mobile application launching in
its own window, no browser
around it, a full- screen mode
with a game or you can bring
browser UI in if you haven't
completely converted to an app
friendly UI.
Finally, you want to point
provide icons and you have to
provide a big array of sizes and
that's a hassle.   Remembering
the names of all of this stuff
and what I have to do, it is a
hassle.  I built a little tool,
the web app manifest generator.
I will take a moment to show
you what it looks like.  Here it
is.  We can put in teamoji,
team status, my name, short
name, let's see I want pa nice
material design amber for this
-- a nice material design amber
for this.  That's what I'm
feeling.  I'll paste that in.
app is designed for portrait
mode and I have to pick an icon,
I'll pick the logo.  This will
generate a zip file that
contains your manifest and
resized icons for all of the
different sizes you'll need.
This is not implicated tool but
saves you time, makes it easier
to get started.  You have no
excuse not to add this to the
application.
I will install this web app
manifest and what is the result?
If I look at my web app on my
phone after installing the web
app manifest I'll see a home
screen icon if I do add to home
screen.  I'll get a home screen
install banner if I use that web
app manifest and some of the
other technologies we'll talk
about in a few minutes.
If I load the app I see the nice
flash screen, rather than a
blank white page of Chrome
trying to load the app I see the
nice splash screen that waits
until the application started to
load to kick it over to the
browser.
I see there is a nice-themed
title bar.  With a few minutes
of work, adding the file in the
application, referencing it,
then we have already made the
app feel more at home on mobile.
Now our users are happier.
What's next?  You may have seen
the statistic recently that the
average website is now as big as
the original Doom game from the
early 90s, over 2mig.  When you
go to a website, on average
you're downloading 2megs worth
of content.  That sounds like a
lot.  It is.  I want you to keep
something in mind.  Web apps
are kind of held to a higher
standard here.   If you look at
the top three applications in
Android each one of those is
over 30megs.  You install those,
that's 15 times the average if
website.  Web apps are held to a
different standard,
traditionally every time we go
to the web app we're loading all
of that content again unless we
get lucky with recent browser
cache.
There has to be a better way.
There is.
We can off line the app shell.
The app shell if you built
single-page applications, that's
the java script, HDMHL, the
images that make up your web
applications Chrome, not the
user data but the stuff that
needs to boot strap in the
browser for the application to
be able to run.
If we want this to be available
offline so that our users have a
fast experience even with slow
connectivity we're going to use
service worker.
Service worker is a new
low-level browser perimeter
active allowing you to install a
java script running in the
background whether or not you
have a web application open.
If you do have it open, if runs
in the background, you pass
messages, if you don't have it
open the service worker can
intercept network requests and
decide how to handle it.  It can
intercept the request and say
hey, I have a version of this
locally, I'll serve that up
instead.  You can do really
cool, complex offline tasks
using the service worker.
There is only two things you
have to know -- to do to use
service worker.  First, you need
a secure connection, service
worker only works over SSL.  It
works on local hosts so that
you're not totally in trouble if
you're doing the local
development.  If you're
deploying to a production server
it has to be running SSL.
The other thing that they need,
it is a had complex
understanding of browser
networking semantics and to
write that code to handle it
appropriately.  This is not
simple.   This is powerful, it
is not simple.  That's actually
great.
Service worker, it gives us
powerful primitives that we at
developers can build on top of
to make an easier experience.
that we need?  First of all, if
you need a secure site I
recommend Firebase hosting, you
get a free custom design domain
and bring that, it we'll
provision a certificate for you,
you don't do anything, it all
just works.  I'm excited about
that, I have wanted it for a
long time.
>> [Applause].
>> MICHAEL BLEIH: The other
thing that you can use is a
library called SW free cache, an
open source library giving up
an easy way to generate service
worker java script.  This is a
task that you would run in your
normal web app approximately
build process generating a
service worker for you and doing
most of the heavy lifting to
get your app shell ready to go
off line.  There is two types of
data.  It has static files, are
that will be the actual
application file in your project
directory, it all of the java
script, HTML, all of that stuff
and it caches a remote file,
fonts from Google fonts or
loading images you can cache
those on demand with this as
well.
Let's take a had look of how to
cache the static files:  This is
Gulp as an example, this is
just a node module, you can
install it or run it
independently as a command line
tool.  I'm defining if the task,
generate service worker.  I
require my free cache library
and then I just point it to the
service worker java script I
want to generate.  It is
important to note that the
service worker should be in the
root of your web application
because server workers only work
on things that are at the same
level or lower in the browser
hierarchy.  You want to put it
at the root so that the service
worker can do everything you
need it to do.
Next, a cache ID, probably the
name of the app, I provide the
static files I want to cache.
I'm picking everything from my
build directory and you may or
may not want to do it depending
on the size of the application.
There are limits to the caches
and things will be evicted if
it is big, you have to tune,
play with it until you have the
right stuff to boot strap really
fast.
Finally, we strip the prefix
disk so the urls work and it is
all going to work.
No big deal.
The next thing, you register the
service worker.  First we're
going to detect if
the browser has service worker.
If we have service worker we
call navigator.service worker
and point to the service worker.
This returns a pro police that
will complete when the service
worker is registered or, of
course, we can see if any errors
happen and deal with that.
This is a simple way to get
started with service worker.  We
have the files offline by
generating this service worker
and we have registered it in the
browser.
The other thing to do, it is
cache remote files, it adding
additional configuration to the
free cache for run time caching.
This is for a cache-first
strategy, that means that web
fonts don't change often.  I can
depend on the version here
because the network version
won't be any different.  It will
respond immediately.  For other
things, profile pictures,
Firebase storage URLs from
things you up loaded, those are
things that may change.  You
want to use network first.  That
just says go to the network, if
I get a response, use the
network response.  If I don't,
use the cache response to work
off line.  That's the precache,
that's ouchline.  We'll add this
to teamoji.
I'll go over here, pull up the
file.
The first thing I'll do is
define that go task.  This is it
what I just showed you with a
bit more configuration, nothing
too different.  I'll add that in
the build process, generate
service worker.
have to register it as well.
I have this app that's loaded
immediately and then I'll
register the service worker in
there.
I have added a bit of extra
logic here.  One of the things
you may have seen if used Google
Inbox or other progressive web
apps, they pop-up a
notification, a new version is
available, click to refresh.
That's here.  We can detect if a
service worker was already
installed and just upgraded and
we can display amy me of message
saying a new version, you may
want to refresh or if it is a
first time, we can let people
know, hey, it is now offline
ready.
Now we have added this to the go
file, we have added it to our
application java script.  Let's
build it, see what happens.
I'm going back over here.
I'll use my full network
connection to get the first page
load.  Now you can see at the
bottom Teamoji is offline ready.
I'm out and about now, I'm not
on a great connection, I'm on
-- that's harsh, let's go to
regular 2G.  I'll refresh the
page.  You can see that loaded
up in a couple of seconds versus
the 15 seconds it took before.
By adding a few lines of code
-- sorry.  If you want to
applaud, go ahead!
>> [Applause]. with a few
lines of code in the gulp file,
a simple service worker
registration in the app it java
script we have made our app more
usable on poor connectivity
experiences.
Our app isn't going to work
completely off line yet.   We're
just caching the shell.  What's
after that?  Well, Pacific --
sorry.  Now the user is happier,
now moving on.
Of course the final goal of this
is to have a truly first class
experience.  If you can have
offline data, if your
application can work when there
is no connectivity at all the
web application stands
Toe-to-toe with world class
native applications.  There is
no difference from your user's
perspective.  They can use it
off line, snappy, responsive,
all of the things that they're
looking for and you don't have
to go native to get the
advantages.
Finally, we're going to offline
the data in the application.  To
do that, actually a quick
caveat before continuing, this
is the part that's most app
specific.   There are different
strategies you may want to use
when going offline.  For some
applications, you may need to
store a draft of a document and
then when you go back online you
sync it.  Other applications
and many, all you really need is
a view of what they were last
looking at and that's useful
enough.
For this example we're going to
use a read-only offline cache.
Firebase database, you take it,
display it directly in the
browser normally, but in order
to support a full offline reload
situation I'm going to put one
step in the middle.  I'll add an
index mirror.   I'll take all
of that data from the realtime
database and mirror it locally
to an offline database available
in most had browsers.  Then I'm
going to use the browser only
to access that offline mirrored
data.  By using the browser only
against the index DB data that
means that when I'm off line the
browser doesn't know the
difference.  It is just reading
the same data it was already
reading but when I'm online I
can use the browser to push
directly into Firebase and
update changes.
This is a relatively simple
thing to implement but offers
powerful features by mirroring
all of the data locally.  I'll
get a little help from the
friends at Polymer.  Two things
I'm excited to announce:  The
first, polymer fire, an official
set of polymer to Firebase.
[Applause].
>> MICHAEL BLEIH: The second
thing, app storage, built by the
Polymer team as part of the
Polymer app toolkit providing
easy ways to do things like
mirroring data offline.  We'll
use the two things together to
take our data and make it
available completely offline.
We'll see how it works.
First, this is Polymerfire.
I'll import into the application
-- if you're not familiar with
Polymer, the link import is the
a script source, you're
importing into the application.
element to set up and configure
my Firebase application.  All of
the data that you need to put
into this, it is available from
the Firebase console for your
project.  You take those values,
you copy and paste them in the
application, you put one
Firebase application in the page
and it is initial rised across
everything.
-- initialized across
Then Firebase off, I have to put
that in the page.   I'll select
a provider, I'll use Google
Authentication and bind the user
in the application.  The user
will be null if I'm not signed
in.  It will be various user
data if I'm signed in.  How do I
get there?  I have a simple log
in function, the sign in with
pop-up method, this mirrors the
standard Firebase SDK in java
script which has a sign in flow
and it binds in the application
and flows through.  The
application code, it is simple.
I can display a welcome message
if I detect there is a user and
a log in screen if there is not
a user.
For the Firebase database,
things are also very simple.
If I want to sync a document, an
individual document, say I have
user preferences, I want to
sync all of the preferences in
the prowser and use that.  I use
the Firebase document element.
I provide a path to the
document that I want to sync and
I bind that data from the data
property into the application.
element allowing me to quarry
collections in Firebase using
the same quarry properties that
the Firebase database allows and
sync that data in my path.
This is how I originally built
teamoji with these elements, I
built the application and at
this point it is still not
offline.  While the Firebase
database supports offline if you
lose connectivity and come back
online, if I hard refresh the
page, all of that data, it is
gone.  It is just an in-memory
cache.  One extra step,
integrate the app mirror.  Here
is the Firebase element, I'm
quarrying updates from a user,
the current user I'm binding
into the path, I'm providing
some various quarry elements or
quarry properties and now I'm
going to import app index DB
mirror p that's from the app
storage element.
An index DB mirror does what you
saw in the diagram.   It takes
data that is bound into it
creating an offline mirror of
it, making that available to the
browser whether or not you have
connectivity.
The way I'll do this, first,
I'll bind the data from my
Firebase
query rather in a public
variable I will do a private
variable, the updates, then I
add a mirror element and this
actually mirrors in many ways
the properties of the Firebase
element.  I have a key that
tells them where to store it and
a great thing on this key, as
that user UDI changes, loading
different data, if I have, you
know, a switcher where I pick
between multiple things, all of
that data will be cached off
line to the different keys so I
can have the same UI state
change and all of that data even
when offline.
The session property there
simply says if this value
changes we want to wipe out
everything.  If I have a user
that logs out and a different
user logs in, they're not going
to see the other user data, it
will be wiped away.
What I do with the app index DB
mirror is bind the updates
variable that I pulled out of
Firebase query in the data
property and then for the
application I use the
persistence data property, the
data that's been persisted into
the index DB.  That's all there
is to it.  When I have
implemented the app index mirror
alongside Firebase query, the
data will be available off line.
Let's look at
that.  Going in the main app
element here moo.  I'm going to
-- here you see that the only
data that this app needs is some
preferences, updates for the
current team I'm looking at and
the list of teams.  It.
What I'll do, I'll take all of
those, I'll replace them with
equivalence with the app index
mirror.  This is exactly the
same pattern I showed you,
mirroring in the key, using the
session, everything you just
saw.  That's what makes the data
available offline.
You   Another thing I'll show
you here, it is how to use the
browser to detect offline state
so that you can change your UI.
Since I'm implementing a
read-only offline cache that
means I shouldn't be showing my
users a button where they can
make an update if they're not
able to while offline.
Ear here in an initialization
function I'm going to show a
little java script in.  This is
straight from the browser.
There isn't anything special
about
this.   Navigator.online tells
me if I am or not online
according to the browser.  This
is no connectivity versus some,
even with the world's worst
connection, it will still be
online but it gives you a
semblance of when you're totally
offline.  I'll listen to both
online and offline events and
set a property on my main app
element.
I have already done some work of
wiring in data to change UI
state throughout the it
application.  Remember, all I'm
really doing to change all of
that is setting offline to true
or false based on whether I
detect that from the browser p
browser.  I'll save
that.  I'll rebuild the
application.
When it is ready
-- now I'm going to refresh.
I'm going to turn off throttling
for a moment.
I just refreshed out of it.  You
can see for a moment that a
banner popped up at the bottom
saying a new version is
available, click to refresh.
Oops.
Oh.
I missed actually importing --
yeah, the app index mirror
element.  That didn't work first
try.  We'll give it another
spin.
The server has started.
Refleshing.
Refreshing.
Now you can see I'm online, my
data works.  I'm feeling a
little bit better again.
I'm feeling good.  Now I'm going
to do something that to me at
least seems like a bad idea to
do in a live demo.  I'll turn
off my wi-fi.
I'm offline.  As you see, the UI
state pretty quickly changed
and     and reflected hey,
you're offline.  This would have
worked with normal Firebase
java script, are it keeps an
in-memory cache and everything
will work fine as long as I
don't refresh the page.  Let's
refresh the page.  It is back
online and my app is fully
offline.
>> [Applause].
>> MICHAEL BLEIH: So that's how
we build a progressive web app.
That's how we make users not
just like our application but
love it by providing them the
features and the utility that
they need regardless of
connectivity, regardless of
device, if they use this on the
desktop, use it on their phone,
it is all the same, it all works
great and that's the promise of
progressive web apps.
Now that we have taken our
application to the next level
what do we do after that?  Well
there is several things to do.
Of course you can implement
offline write, you can make it
so that you can compose data
offline, going online, it will
sync.  The polymer fire app
storage duo does support this.
There is a code lab available
linked from the end of the the
talk that you can go through
showing you not only how to
create a read-only cache but how
to create write offline data.
We can also use the web push
API, a new standard that allows
you to receive notifications
whether or not the app is open
on the web.  You can use
Firebase Cloud messaging to send
the messages to the browser
users and they'll receive that
as a native notification from
Chrome and they'll be able to
click and reengage.
You can also do a surprising
amount of things with the web
and phones.  There is a cool
website,
whatwebcandodto, go there and
you can see all of the things
that your phone can handle.
from Geo location, taking
pictures, accessing blue tooth
beacons or the gyro, a ton of
stuff that I didn't realize
until I saw the site that you
can do today with phone
capabilities in the browser.
Progressive web apps, they're
about building layer upon layer
to make your app experience
better, to make your user's
experience better, and to make
great web apps.
That's all I've got.  Thank you
for listening.
If you're interested in hearing
more, I'll be at the Firebase
office hours on stage 6 in 15
minutes.  Everything I presented
is available on
get
GitHub, if you want to learn
more, we can chat in the Google
space.
Thank you.
[Applause].
Fireside Chat:  Firebase in the
Real World. May 20th.
FB16.
Fireside Chat:  Firebase in the
Real World. May 20th.
FB16.
Fireside Chat:  Firebase in the
Real World. May 20th.
FB16.
Fireside Chat:  Firebase in the
Real World. May 20th.
FB16.
Fireside Chat:  Firebase in the
Real World. May 20th.
FB16.
Fireside Chat:  Firebase in the
Real World. May 20th.
FB16. Fireside Chat:  Firebase
in the Real World. May 20th.
FB16.
Fireside Chat:  Firebase in the
Real World. May 20th.
FB16. Fireside Chat:  Firebase
in the Real World. May 20th.
FB16.
Fireside Chat:  Firebase in the
Real World. May 20th.
FB16.
Fireside Chat:  Firebase in the
Real World. May 20th.
FB16.
Fireside Chat:  Firebase in the
Real World. May 20th.